[Musique]
allô allô
à la télé les journaux tout le monde ah
le truc mais oui ce matin je suis allé
au pressing mais attends mais tout le
monde en parle tu sais que j'ai eu le
truc en ligne là
tout le monde en parle
bienvenue sur le plateau de Tout le
monde en parle vous connaissez le
principe tout le monde en parle alors
tout le monde en parle
vous connaissez kale et Olivier les
voici
merci
je vous demande de vous arrêter merci
toi publiquement
tous les soirs
ça quand vous arrivez chez vous aussi
bien alors j'ai reçu beaucoup de
courrier sur le sur le vidéo sans pleurs
là je vais vous montrer ce que c'est
pour ceux qui n'était pas la semaine
dernière
[Musique]
voilà donc ça ça c'est la récompense ça
c'est quand les invités trouvent des
blind test en général c'est CAD qui les
trouve tous bonsoir
alors j'ai eu beaucoup de courrier me
disant c'est formidable mais alors quand
les gens ne trouvent pas quand les gens
sont pas bons dans les interviews il
faut quand même trouver une
punitions alors on a imaginé celle-là
c'est
la danse
[Musique]
voilà c'est horrible
il vaut mieux répondre aux interviews
parce que sinon c'est bouli sinon
nabouli voilà
mise à part Kad et Olivier bouli je
recevrai ce soir et Mathieu Berg
à la cuisine
Gilbert Collard
Jennifer Poissy
et sereine Prévost
bien alors vous savez qu'une tradition
cette émission pour ceux qui suivent pas
régulièrement je sais qu'il y en a
encore chaque semaine on regarde les
meilleurs moments de la semaine
précédente donc ça s'appelle tout le
monde en a parlé on va se voir alors
[Musique]
la question Pierre Bellemare comment
vendreiez-vous un vibromasseur qui se
branche sur la lune cigare Frédéric
Diefenthal moi j'en ai rien à je
fume pas
dites-moi après monsieur
donc on parle pas de la guerre d'Algérie
mais on l'évoque d'une certaine on
évoque d'une certaine date
le pas de Vannes déplacée pas de pas de
conneries sur le sexe
vous entraîner le matin
on fait tous nous fais pas le même geste
c'est pour ça
bravo bravo
c'est un peu trop à gauche quand même
si
et vous avez de quoi rouler un pétard là
évidemment
pétard en début de soirée après je passe
à autre chose quand même mais je croyais
que vous aviez arrêté la coque Henri
5 fois
voilà
c'est le best of de la semaine dernière
maintenant on va recevoir une très très
jolie fille dans Taxi 2 à les Petra une
policière avec un gros flingue qui
n'hésite pas à le sortir comme un taxi 1
derrière et ce mois-ci elle est
également la fiche d'un film qui
s'appelle sauvetage explosif Simon 16
entre le basketteur de Nice Rodman et
l'ex to be tree Philippe piccolique
voici et Monsieur Berg
vous êtes très très jolie c'est vrai
merci
j'adore les gens
donc vous êtes là effectivement on va
parler de Taxi 2 on va parler de Simon
16 sauvetage explosif mais d'abord on a
un duplex avec Cannes puisque vous savez
que c'est le Festival de Cannes en ce
moment Claudia Schiffer bonsoir bonsoir
alors vous n'êtes pas un petit peu déçu
d'être au Festival de Cannes pour
L'Oréal et pas pour un pas pour un film
non c'est avec grand plaisir que je suis
là j'étais ici avec blackout il y a 4
ans et là je suis avec L'Oréal et c'est
aussi bien et malheureusement il pleut
donc ça c'est pas trop génial alors vous
avez une enfance très heureuse dans une
famille harmonieuse affectueuse vous
avez été élevé à la campagne j'étais bon
élève vous appreniez le piano vous êtes
très sage vos parents étaient vos idoles
vous lui être avocate comme votre père
vous avez pas eu de crise d'adolescence
et puis un jour dans une boîte de nuit
un jour un jour dans une boîte de nuit à
Düsseldorf vous aviez 17 ans vous étiez
vous étiez jamais vous étiez jamais
venus dans cette boîte de nuit et vous
avez été découverte par le patron d'une
agence de mannequin ça s'est passé
comment Claudia
j'y croyais pas je pensais qu'il sentait
en train de faire un fait un faute je me
suis dit les Français en plus alors
peut-être aussi ils sont en train de me
draguer uniquement et
mon père est avocat et ils ont parlé
avec mes parents le lendemain et c'était
plus simple de discuter directement avec
votre Père qui est avocat ça allait plus
vite je me suis dit vaut mieux qu'il
parle avec eux et
j'ai commencé à signer un contrat et je
suis venue après l'école je suis
carrément
elle est à Paris pour commencer est-ce
que cette cet enfant serait très sage
finalement cette nature très studieuse
vous fumez pas vous buvez pas vous
droguez pas est-ce que finalement
ça n'a pas pour conséquence que vous
manquez un petit peu de de cicatrice
intérieure pour faire du cinéma est-ce
que vous croyez pas que c'est un
handicap pour faire du cinéma d'avoir
une vie aussi lisse avant on fait partie
des gens qui pensent qu'il faut prendre
la drogue pour être bien
est-ce que finalement quand on a quand
on a vécu que des choses bien que des
choses gays que des choses heureuses
est-ce qu'on est capable au cinéma
d'exprimer des des sentiments négatifs
et des situations un peu douteuses un
peu glauque un peu triste c'est vrai que
dans le cinéma est moins en tant que je
travaille beaucoup avec mes émotions et
c'est vrai que c'est important d'avoir
des souvenirs dans la vie positif et
négatif et c'est vrai ma vie est normale
comme tout le monde j'ai des apps and
downs comme tout le monde et
le fait que je ne prends pas la drogue
ou que je ne suis pas alcoolique ça
change rien j'ai j'ai quand même les
émotions qui qui font un peu hard et en
bas et
et voilà et j'aime beaucoup rigoler donc
voilà
est-ce que c'est pour ça est-ce que
c'est pour casser un petit peu cette
image un peu un peu lisse que vous avez
accepté le film blackout réalisé par
Abel Ferrara qui avait fait quand même
badlet Nantes avec Hervé quitter est-ce
que c'est parce que c'était un allumé
Ferrara que vous avez accepté ce film
non parce que vous savez je ne fais pas
un film en disant ah bah je vais faire
ce film pour casser mon image j'ai fait
ce film parce que j'adore le réalisateur
et j'aimais beaucoup le scénario et en
plus j'avais jamais fait un film donc
c'est moi c'était énormément excitant de
trouver finalement quelque chose que
j'aimais tellement donc je n'ai jamais
pensé à l'univers de Ferrara est quand
même très très loin de votre univers à
vous non
en plus pour mon caractère dans ce film
par exemple il fallait pas de maquillage
ni de coiffure donc c'était génial je
suis arrivée sur le Seat il y avait rien
à faire et comme c'était très bien film
je ne savais pas si le réalisateur
maintenant était normal entre guillemets
ou si tout le monde était comme ça ou
c'était excentrique vraiment donc il y
avait ma fille me dit une donnée sympa
qui n'arrêtait pas de me dire tu sais
c'est pas normal il est pas normal vous
avez dit inutile de m'envoyer des
scénarios à la Pretty Woman parce que
pour moi ça serait suicidaire de faire
un film comme ça il y a deux choses je
cherche en fait les rôles qui sont très
différents de moi comme par exemple dans
le film blackout ou dans le fait mieux
exemple c'est black and white parce que
je joue quelqu'un qui est pas très
gentil du tout où j'ai par exemple j'ai
fait un autre film en Amérique où je
fais une j'ai chaud une chanteuse
donc j'adore ça c'est très très
différent et en plus de ça je pense que
pour moi en tant débutante j'ai
tellement de choses encore à apprendre
il vaut mieux commencer avec les
expériences dans les petits films avec
les réalisateurs qui sont très ouverts à
travailler avec les débutants alors je
disais que Claudia en commençant cette
interview je disais que vous avez une
vie très très heureuse et tout de suite
beaucoup de succès tout de suite gagner
beaucoup d'argent fait beaucoup de
couverture de magazines pourtant vous
avez une expérience assez négative c'est
quelques années avant de faire le film
Citroën où il y avait le crash test vous
avez failli vous cracher en avion en 96
aux Antilles il y a la porte vous étiez
dans un petit avion et à la porte
arrière qui s'est ouverte oui je vais
faire un voyage en fait à Belize et
c'était un tout petit avion en fait à
peu près pour 4 personnes et
c'était moi dans l'avion derrière il y
avait le pilote devant un seul pilote et
en fait heureusement c'était seulement
un petit voyage huit minutes mais quand
on est quand on a commencé à monter la
porte de mon côté c'est ouvert et
j'avais une ceinture donc j'ai mis la
ceinture autour de le poignet de la
porte et je te la comme ça entre un
espérer j'espère que la porte n'a pas
offrir parce que si elle s'ouvre c'est
fini parce que je m'en vais avec et j'ai
gardé la porte comme ça j'ai essayé de
parler avec le pilote qui était là mais
vous savez porte les grands choses là
sur les oreilles donc c'est pas possible
maman pas entendu et finalement après 8
minutes on est descendu et il y a pas de
problème est-ce que c'était le plus
mauvais moment de votre vie non il y
avait un autre enfin incident dans un
dans un avion il y avait un
un oiseau qui est allé dans un c'était
un avion privé un oiseau est allé dans
un mentor le moteur a commencé à
exploser à prendre du feu et il y avait
plein de
brouillards
et on a fait un crash landing oh là là
heureusement il y avait rien du tout et
crash finalement
j'avais beaucoup de chance alors vous
êtes une fille une fille sage quand même
mais vous avez quand même des rapports
avec les avec les garçons qui sont pas
toujours très clairs quand vous avez
quand on vous a vu quelquefois avec le
prince Albert vous avez dit ce n'est
qu'un ami et l'été dernier quand on a
commencé à vous voir avec le playboy
londonien team Jeffries
on vous a demandé pourquoi vous étiez
avec lui vous aviez vous avez dit ce
n'est qu'un vieil ami alors pourquoi à
chaque fois que on vous voit avec un
garçon vous êtes obligé de dire c'est un
ami ou c'est un vieil ami et menacé de
tribunaux les gens qui écriraient autre
chose est-ce que vous avez un problème
avec les relations avec les hommes avec
les garçons
bon d'abord je dois dire que
si je dis que c'est un ami c'est un ami
si je dis c'est mon amant c'est mon
amour
je suis sûr que c'était pas votre amant
mais Tim Jeffries c'est devenu quand
même un ami très très très proche par la
suite quand même non
c'est la phrase qui a dit ça c'est pas
moi il faut pas te croire vous savez non
non moi quand je dis que c'est un homme
heureux c'est mon petit copain c'est la
vérité si je dis c'est mon ami c'est la
vérité je ne mens pas mais si la presse
marque une chose pareille vous savez le
plus connaît le plus connu connaît et
rien à faire les gens marrent les choses
c'est un ventre des choses disent des
choses même entre guillemets que je n'ai
jamais dit donc rien à faire
pourquoi je dirais que c'était pas vrai
si c'était vrai alors puisque vous dites
toujours la vérité est-ce que c'est vrai
que vous allez vous marier avec Team
Jeffrey's pour l'instant on est fiancé
il y a pas encore une date donc vous
avez changé d'avis un petit peu sur le
mariage parce que en 1998 vous disiez le
mariage c'est pas très important ni même
nécessaire donc vous avez un petit peu
changé d'avis sur le mariage
non en fait c'est ce que j'avais dit
c'est que à ce moment-là le mariage
n'était pas important encore parce que
je pense que si on veut se marrer et
avoir les enfants il faut être contient
quand il va avoir une date sur certains
moments il faut être prête à voyager
moins on peut pas tout faire parce que
c'est important je pense que pour les
enfants qu'on reste à la maison et à
cette époque là et d'ailleurs encore
aujourd'hui je ne suis pas encore prête
pour les enfants parce qu'il y a
tellement de choses que je vais faire
encore c'est encore trop tôt vous allez
pas vous marier tout de suite pas tout
de suite
et alors avec David Copperfield comment
ça s'est terminé parce qu'un journal
allemand qui s'appelle bunt qui avait
publié un contrat entre David copperfil
et vous vous les avez attaqué au
tribunal et vous avez gagné
donc c'était le journal bunto avait
publié des faux documents
ça veut dire ça veut dire donc il y a
jamais eu de contrats d'affaires entre
David Copperfield et vous
ça n'existait
ça veut dire ça non oui oui
non ça prouve encore une fois il faut
pas tout croire même si un papier même
s'il y a tout un coin signature il faut
pas tout croire
merci beaucoup merci Claudia de nous
avoir accordé cette interview exclusive
et bon séjour à Cannes
[Musique]
et voilà Claudia Schiffer a gagné quand
même le vidéo sans pleurs des danseuses
parce que c'était bien sinon elle aurait
bouli qui fait la danse des canards
voilà c'est clair pour tout le monde bon
alors maintenant on va parler un petit
peu
vous savez pas faire ça ah j'avais très
vite alors donc vous êtes dans Taxi vous
étiez dans Taxi vous êtes en Taxi 2 vous
jouez Petra il y a beaucoup de Top
Models qui ont voulu faire du cinéma il
y en a qui arrivent il y en a qui vous
ça marche plutôt bien merci après
Taction vous avez dit ouf je n'aurais
pas la même carrière que Cindy Crawford
alors vous n'aurez pas la même carrière
que Cindy Crawford je suis pas parce que
microphone super modèle qui est une
microphone c'est bon j'ai pas travaillé
au cinéma
j'adore le cinéma mais je suis vraiment
une mannequin qui va réveille futur
concombre idéal c'est vraiment l'arrivée
comme ça on vous a appelé vous l'avez
même pas rappelé c'est dommage vous dit
non à l'expression je crois
qu'un casting avec des sons
pour trouver le rôle de Petra des taxis
qui sort dans ces sauvetages explosifs
Simon 16 alors avec Dennis Rodman qui
est commissaire du ministrement
[Applaudissements]
mon frère qui m'avait obligé donc
c'est ce qu'on appelle le test de l'élan
pour revenir à noble là-bas on se met on
fait ça et alors alors dans ce film il y
a Denis Rodman donc il y a Philippe des
to be tree
pardon le 17 mai je le dis à tous nos
amis qui veulent voir et Monsieur Bert
qui veulent voir Dennis Rodman le grand
basketteur et puis surtout Philippe
pardon
il est pas mal dans le film
bon c'est pas un film de Oscar cette
film c'est une film d'action Dennis
Rodin n'est pas encore un acteur moi je
suis pas une très belle actrice non plus
c'est un film il y a plein d'acteurs
le producteur c'est le producteur des
films de Jean-Claude Van Damme dans le
dans le c'est pas la peine t'inquiète
pas vous avez déclaré d'ailleurs et
Monsieur Berg c'est un film pas très
intellectuel je joue une de
garde du corps qui travaille pour
n'importe qui si on lui donne
suffisamment d'argent c'est vrai
si je te file ce truc tu me laisses
partir contente-toi de me donner le
disque
[Musique]
Simon 16 sauvetage
explosifère que notre invité ce soir
Dennis Rodman et Philippe et tout vitré
pardon alors quand vous êtes il y a des
scènes quand même dans le film moi j'ai
vu le film il y a des scènes quand même
vous êtes avec Dennis Rodman vous aviez
une doublure dans le sein pour le combat
bien sûr parce que c'est impossible
c'est pas très dur parce que c'est un
film américain toi tu vas pas vraiment
et moi je suis un problème avec ça
il y a pas d'autres mots
c'est vrai que c'est vrai que Denis il
avait un petit slip cher c'est vrai il y
avait quoi dans le slip quelque chose
alors vous est-ce que vous portiez vos
petits poussins en silicone que dans
comme vous avez que dans Taxi vous aviez
des petits des petits coussins en
silicone
vous transpiriez il y avait les coussins
qui bougent
alors ce qu'il faut savoir mesdames
messieurs quand même c'est que quand
elle était adolescente et Monsieur Berg
était
ouais majorette non vous étiez pas non
vous trouviez pas belle quoi vous étiez
grandes on vous appelez le troll le
troll
mais je crois que c'est beaucoup
mannequin la même histoire très grande
maigre
grande bouche avec appareil dentaire
parce que
tout le mannequin avait dit le même
histoire
c'est un conte de fées l'histoire des
Mathieu Berck un jour elle est à une
copine vous connaissez
là elle est là elle est comme un petit
peu comme Claudia Schiffer d'ailleurs
je sais pas ce qui se passe on serait
samedi soir voilà on parle vous devez
vous dansez non n'importe quoi et alors
donc vous êtes dans une boîte de nuit il
y a une shopping et alors il y a des
gens qui viennent vous voir c'est des
gens qui travaillent pour une crème
solaire et qui vous demande de monter
sur scène en bikini et donc voilà et
donc et Monsieur Berck se retrouve donc
avec les choisis pour faire un concours
à Stockholm et elle se retrouve voilà
choisis et alors là vous vous étiez pas
du tout fait pour faire ça vous faisiez
du elle faisait des études supérieures
de marketing international ça se voit et
alors vous faites ce concours là pour le
produit de beauté la crème solaire et
puis six mois après c'est le succès vous
retrouvez à Paris à Milan alors il est
devenue tellement star et Monsieur Berg
en Suède qu'elle a eu un talk show vous
avez eu un talk show à la télévision un
peu comme comme Estelle Hallyday ou
comme une ça a marché
c'est pas sympa
[Musique]
donc voilà vous devenez top model vous
faites des centaines de couvertures pour
des magazines des défilés etc et moi en
fait je vous ai connu
dans un clip réalisé par mon ami
Jean-Baptiste mondinot et je pouvais pas
savoir comment j'ai aimé ce clip
[Musique]
j'attends Noël et voilà et Monsieur Bert
dans tandem
guitariste avec les seins à l'air comme
ça Jean-Baptiste Monino tandem chanté
par Vanessa Paradis une chanson de Serge
Gainsbourg
il a même les réponses quand c'est pas
le blind test Gainsbourg
et Monsieur Berg est devenu une énorme
star dans les pays nordiques parce que
elle était avec Monsieur
[Musique]
attention
et voilà avec lequel
avec une
sortie avec eux
ouf
alors évidemment de avec oulf est devenu
une énorme star encore plus star que ce
qu'elle était comme Claudia Schiffer on
vous a prêté une aventure avec le prince
Albert c'est fou ce qu'on lui prête
comme aventure
avec des filles le pauvre salsa
tourne le Taxi 2 à Marseille il
m'appelle pour cette tournée golf Monaco
je connais les longtemps avec
si cette saison elle m'appelle pour tu
vas venir pour le week-end j'étais à
Marseille Tournai pourquoi pas pourquoi
tu dis non une fois ça ta vie peut
arriver avec un prince avec le livre
aussi
il est très gentil c'est ça tout le
monde dit ça
il est très gentil j'ai rien fait avec
lui c'est vrai c'est ce que les filles
disent NON
je confirmer vraiment
il y a pas de problème
je te paye l'avion et alors il y a eu un
truc encore plus dingue c'est qu'un jour
Léonardo Dicaprio le vrai Léonardo
appelle et Monsieur Berg lui dit voilà
je voudrais dîner avec vous deux fois il
vous a appelé
alors Emma Emma à ce moment-là c'était
lui qui était à Paris tournait l'homme
au masque de fer Leonardo et vous à
l'époque vous étiez avec un c'était vous
étiez avec ouf oui
et donc vous lui avez dit non et voilà
aujourd'hui vous diriez pas la même
chose ça dépend
[Applaudissements]
vous étiez très flatté exactement bien
sûr
Léonardo Dicaprio
content
du coup on va concrétiser la différence
avec le prince Albert
non vous avez un problème c'est quand
vous oui c'est que l'odeur l'odeur non
quand est mort quand est mort rencontre
un homme elle voit tout de suite le père
potentiel c'est-à-dire que tout de suite
elle se dit est-ce que ça pourrait être
le père de mes enfants et ça c'est tout
le monde ne peut pas rentrer dans ces
cristaux en même temps ça se voit
problème mais je crois avec mon âge
c'est vrai euh je suis bon quand tu veux
faire le sexe tu fais le sexe bon mais
bon
c'est vrai quand je
comprends pas toi
si vous voulez vous asseoir là la
semaine prochaine bienvenue vous êtes
génial vraiment aujourd'hui je pensais
pour la future c'est vrai je veux bien
une famille elle aime avoir le sentiment
d'appartenir à quelqu'un ça c'est bon
pour une Suédoise identité d'italienne
moi je pense que les je pensais que les
Suédois c'est des filles très libérés
non
voilà donc je dis à nos amis
téléspectateurs et Mathieu Berck
cherchent un papa pour ses enfants
oui c'est bon
vous vous j'en sais rien vous tout votre
argent vous le mettez en action en
obligation donc c'est un bon parti
téléspectateurs et alors vous êtes en
plus quelqu'un d'assez mystique vous
avez été attiré à ces jeunes par la par
la religion vous faisiez partie ça je
sais pas ce que c'est du Livet art c'est
quoi c'est une petite patine secte mais
c'est une secte ou l'école secte pas
pour boire mais c'était une
question protestante
de la Suède
et c'est pourquoi personne dans
l'anglais c'est pourquoi je suis arrivée
dans une petite croix
voilà Emma était quelqu'un de très
religieux elle est toujours et alors là
est-ce que vous savez comment s'appelait
le patron de cette de c'est pas une sac
d'ailleurs mais cette église disons
comment on dit aux États-Unis
et on souhaite on dit ouf ta chambre
pour que nos amis téléspectateurs
puissent se faire une idée très précise
sur le mental le psychisme des Mathieu
Berg on va faire une petite interview
psy et on ne bouge pas par un jingle ah
on bouge plus
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
voulez-vous relaxer un petit peu avant
de commencer
j'ai vu gongli la télévision cette
semaine dire que le Tibet est une
province de la Chine
alors
est-ce que vous êtes parano
non pas vraiment est-ce que vous êtes
schizo temps en temps avec mon travail
est-ce que vous êtes maso
est-ce que vous êtes est-ce que vous
êtes sado pas trop non
géronto géronto
âgées les mecs de 50 ans
mais c'est pas vraiment
est-ce que vous êtes porno ça veut dire
qu'on regarde les cassettes
viens est-ce que vous êtes féticho non
mais mon travail c'est vraiment
mannequin aussi je crois c'est bien
est-ce que vous êtes pédo non bien sûr
non OK
génial
et maintenant
deuxième duplex avec Cannes où a lieu le
Festival de Cannes
bienvenue
Mathilde Seigner bonsoir bonsoir alors
Mathilde jeudi soir vous avez monté les
marches pour la présentation du film
Harry un ami qui vous veut du bien de
Dominique molle avec Sergi Lopez c'est
un des quatre films français en
compétition quel effet ça vous a fait
Mathilde d'être la reine d'un soir à
Cannes bah c'est non c'est
extraordinaire d'autant plus que je dis
on a eu une mais innovation quoi le film
a été vraiment mais je le dis la fille
prétentieuse très très applaudi non ça a
été incroyable je sais pas si tous les
films sont applaudis comme ça mais en
tout cas là pendant un quart d'heure les
gens étaient debout et c'était très très
émouvant quoi en fait c'est moi moi qui
disais Cannes je m'en fous machin en
fait je suis très contente c'est vrai
que le film est comparé en dit un petit
peu que ça va être comme la vie rêvée
des anges pour l'an 2000 c'est vrai
c'est possible c'est encore mieux moi
que la vie rêvée des anges mais alors
c'est vrai que vous au départ vous
jouiez le jeu de Cannes avec un petit
peu de recul un petit peu de distance
en parlant de la grande foire canoise et
finalement vous avez quand même vous
avez été séduite quoi ouais non mais je
râle je râle et puis après en fait je
suis vachement contente mais là je suis
super contente un peu fatiguée mais je
suis contente quand vous étiez enfant en
fait vous aviez pas du tout rêvé de
faire du cinéma vous lui êtes comédienne
de théâtre vous vous pensiez que vous
étiez pas alors c'est incroyable ça vous
pensiez que j'étais pas assez belle pour
faire du du cinéma au lieu de chanteuse
non je pensais pas exactement ça je
pensais que que pour faire du cinéma
fallait être très jolie mais parfaite
quoi genre mais comme Bardot tout des
corps parfaits pas de rien quoi sublime
et en fait donc voilà donc je pense donc
je me disais que moi je pouvais pas en
faire mais en fait j'en fais bon et en
fait
la fille qui dit en fait tout le temps
et en fait genre ça va quoi on s'en fout
enfin il y a pas que des belles quoi
bien alors on va parler un petit peu du
film ouais d'accord il y a une pub alors
un ami qui vous fait du bien de
Dominique molle qui avait fait un
intimité en 93 c'est un film de genre
c'est un polar c'est un polar c'est un
film de genre et c'est un film qui
renoue un peu enfin à mes yeux avec les
films de clouzo en tout cas le film pour
moi elle a vraiment la qualité d'un des
films de Clouseau des diaboliques et de
tout ça un peu Chabrol un peu Melville
mais et puis beaucoup Hitchcock aussi et
beaucoup romane Polanski et beaucoup
tout ça quoi alors c'est l'histoire d'un
type qui s'incruste dans la dans la vie
d'un couple de jeunes Français moyen et
puis qui va tuer pour des raisons que je
dévoile pas parce qu'il faut voir le
film parce que c'est des raisons très
étranges quand même oui c'est-à-dire qui
pousse en fait son copain qu'il retrouve
après beaucoup de temps il le pousse à
larguer sa vie banale à devenir écrivain
c'est ça oui à devenir écrivain parce
qu'il écrivait des poèmes quand il était
jeune et il le pousse à ça et en fait il
le débarrasse enfin il tue pour faire le
bien il a l'impression que il l'aime
quoi il tue par amour il l'aime et il
élimine beaucoup de gens autour de lui
en croyant faire le bien
on s'entend parfaitement au lit c'est le
plaisir à l'état pur geek
parce que c'est amené à rien et comme
son deuxième prénom c'est Richard mais
je n'aime pas non plus Richard et que le
diminutif de Richard en anglais sedic
j'appelle geek
et pour en revenir à notre qui m'a fait
découvrir ton poème
tu faisais de la poésie
dans le journal du lycée les grands
poignards
pour moi c'est un classique
[Applaudissements]
alors Mathilde vous apparaissez quand
même vous vous aviez peur d'être assez
joli pour faire du cinéma vous
apparaissez en tous les cas comme une
vraie nature et avec un vrai franc
parler alors j'ai un petit peu réfléchi
à vous je me suis dit pourquoi elle est
comme ça alors j'ai trouvé trois raisons
la première raison c'est que vous êtes
cAPRICORNE Vous avez un foutu caractère
mais un certain goût de la franchise et
de l'authenticité vous trichez pas quoi
non non pas du tout la deuxième raison
c'est là tavisme c'est votre grand-père
Louis Seigner qu'un immense comédien
qu'on a vu quand on était petit en noir
et blanc dans le dans le bourgeois
gentilhomme et vous dites mon côté
bourru ça vient de lui oui parce que
parce que je suis plutôt une jeune
bourgeoise enfin j'ai vécu à Paris et
voilà et mon grand-père était quand même
de d'un homme de la terre oui je pense
que j'ai pris ce côté saigné assez brut
de décoffrage
curieux mélange d'ailleurs quand vous
dites quand on vous parle du cinéma on
vous dit ça marche pour vous en ce
moment et que vous dites faut taper dans
la crème tant qu'il y en a ça vous plaît
c'est une vraie expression de la
campagne ça quand même oui c'est ça
c'est une expression de de mon fiancé
d'ailleurs ah d'accord je vais voler ah
d'accord on a 3e raison donc il y a le
côté Capricorne la franchise il y a
votre grand-père lui il s'est mis le
côté terrien et puis votre famille c'est
à vos parents vous dites dans ma famille
on pouvait tout dire donc je dis tout
Oui c'est-à-dire que moi j'ai été élevé
dans une vraie liberté avec les qualités
et les défauts enfin les choses bien et
pas bien que ça ça engendre mais en tout
cas à la maison on pouvait tout dire
voilà on hurlait si on avait envie il y
avait une liberté qui fait que moi
aujourd'hui et ben je vois pas pourquoi
je me priverais vous êtes très franche
dans un univers souvent hypocrite c'est
souvent
et vous dites moi je trouve ça normal
d'être France ce sont les autres qui qui
sont pas normaux et on je me dis souvent
on fait attention à ce que tu dis et
vous dites je ne vais pas me polisser je
ne vais pas m'asseseptiser pour devenir
comme les autres non non mais je pense
en plus j'ai beaucoup réfléchi depuis la
dernière fois que je suis venu à votre
émission
et depuis le temps à passer et tout ça
et c'est encore pire qu'avant
c'est-à-dire que je pense que faut pas
systématiquement dire des horreurs pour
dire des horreurs d'abord ça veut rien
dire je dis pas des horreurs mais je
changerai rien de rien voilà mon agent
est pas loin d'ailleurs je vois qu'elle
bon mais rien de rien et en plus ça m'a
pas empêché de travailler je crois que
ça m'empêchera pas et de toute façon si
j'ai un trou et je dois avoir un trou je
l'aurais non mais vous êtes vous dites
je suis toujours la même qu'au lycée
Lavoisier je suis toujours aussi chiante
oui j'ai toujours été j'ai toujours dit
ce que je pensais et les gens du métier
peuvent dire oui c'est de la provocation
elle se donne un genre les méchants
c'est purement authentique et je le jure
mais sur ce que j'ai de plus cher au
monde je peux pas m'empêcher je suis je
dis ce que je ressens je suis comme ça
et puis et puis c'est comme ça on prend
comme je suis hein voilà vous le jurez
donc la tête de Laurent Gerra de Laurent
Gerra oh oui oui
parfois vous vous demandez si on n'a pas
lobotomiser les gens tellement vous
trouvez qu'il y a une pensée unique un
politiquement correcte envahissant vous
demandez si les gens ont pas été
lobotomisés non je me demande si je me
demande pourquoi ils ont peur et de quoi
ils ont peur c'est-à-dire je vois pas
une actrice ou un acteur elles peur de
dire ce qu'on pense mais de quoi elle va
avoir peur l'actrice quand elle va
sortir
non on va rien lui faire mais simplement
c'est parce que je pense qu'ils ont peur
quoi de plus travailler de tout ça mais
ça veut rien dire moi je travaille et je
dis ce que je pense bon bah voilà vous
avez pas peur de dire ce que vous pensez
par exemple bon vous aimez pas le rap
c'est connu vous l'avez déjà dit vous
dites
par exemple
ils sont immondes ils sont absolument
laids ils leur manque que les crottes de
nez ils font des albums de merde
mais est-ce que c'est vrai que vous
préférez ça
[Musique]
c'est pas possible vous préférez pas
quand même Lara Fabian NTM ah non ah bon
d'accord
dire du mal de NTM c'est encore bon
c'est relativement admis mais en
revanche vous dit du mal de Zazie vous
dites on comprend rien à ce qu'elle dit
on dirait un ver de terre qui se dandine
je suis désolé mais ça c'est tout des
choses
vous êtes coca je dis rien voilà je dis
plus rien j'adore Zazie NTM j'adore
j'adore le rap en fait la vérité j'aime
le rap profondément en moi mais c'est
très compliqué mais vous êtes
revenons au cinéma vous vous moquez un
petit peu des actrices françaises qui
veulent faire des des carrières au
cinéma en Amérique vous dites elle
ferait mieux déjà de faire des carrières
correctes en France non mais c'est pas
ça c'est que moi on me dit tu parles pas
anglais c'est pas bien et tout je ne
veux pas parler anglais parce que
ou alors si quand je voyage pour
demander un jus à l'hôtel mais et je
sais même pas le demander mais c'est
vrai que que je m'en fiche parce que
j'ai envie de faire une carrière en
France et déjà dur de durer en France et
que pour aller faire 10 phrases dans des
panouses ou montrer ses fesses pour les
Américains car au fond faut bien savoir
que les rôles des rôles qui est sublime
aux États-Unis sont les Américains qui
les ont et c'est normal ils vont pas
aller prendre des frenchies qui parlent
mal et quand un accent genre un machin
comme ça alors pour rester dans le
cinéma vous n'êtes pas très cinémat
branché vous êtes pas par exemple vous
aimez pas tellement le le cinéma de
d'Assayas qui pourtant un film à Cannes
les Destinées sentimentales tirés du
roman de Jacques Chardonne vous dites en
parlant de d'Assayas vous dites j'aime
pas son cinéma j'ai pas envie Thierry de
parler tout ça je préfère parler d'Harry
quoi vous êtes en train de devenir un
peu comme les autres je deviens pas
comme les autres ça m'arrivera jamais
mais c'est vrai que à un moment donné
épidémies et tout après ça blesse les
gens voilà parlons de quelqu'un qui est
pas à Cannes Tarantino par exemple vous
avez dit que vous préfériez Claude
sauter à Tarantino ah mais ça c'est
clair oui
parlons de quelqu'un que vous allez
peut-être croisé à Cannes Jean-Luc
Godard il vous a donné un rendez-vous il
voulait vous vous faire tourner dans un
film qui s'appelait Forever Mozart et
vous voulez donner le rôle d'un d'un
fruit dans son film vous voulez que
Julien un fruit et vous lui avez dit que
j'ai mis pas son cinéma c'est très fort
c'est quand même pas j'ai jamais
spécialement aimé les films de Godard
oui c'est vrai dites-moi Mathilde
Laurent Gerra bon il a déclaré dans
cette émission Tout le monde en parle
sous la torture avec la question qui tue
il a déclaré qu'il voulait pas se marier
il a pas eu le Molière c'est du meilleur
one man show c'est Arturo Brachetti
qu'il l'a eu est-ce que vous l'aimez
toujours oui bien sûr je l'aime
d'ailleurs par rapport au Molière je
trouve que c'est oh c'est pas très
normal mais en même temps
je me dis que en France on n'aime pas
tellement quand les gens ont trop de
succès donc on donne pas des prix à des
gens contre de succès parce que les
Français sont assez jaloux et je pense
que voilà aussi on lui a pas donné aussi
parce que peut-être c'était trop parce
que c'est pas très juste sur les trois
je pense que c'est Laurent qui méritait
et objectivement on est tous d'accord
merci d'avoir répondu à cette interview
le film s'appelle Harry un ami qui vous
veut du bien et le film sera en salle le
16 août voilà merci sympa
très sympa le film vachement bien en
plus
j'accueille maintenant le leader de la
Ligue communiste révolutionnaire Alain
krivé
de vous avoir alors vous êtes donc comme
je viens de le dire le leader de la
Ligue communiste révolutionnaire alors
dites-moi on va on va faire les choses
calmement parce qu'on est toujours Kevin
la Guillet tout ça ils sont à l'extrême
gauche à la gauche de la gauche alors
assez rapidement sinon je vais être
obligé de vous mosaïker de vous faire
écouter Immo Vrigny et ça personne s'en
remet
autre chose non sérieusement
c'est quoi la LCR c'est-à-dire vous êtes
trop de ski c'est-à-dire vous n'êtes pas
commis vous êtes pas social vous êtes
trop de ski en des mots s'il fallait
expliquer votre position politique parce
que je crois que les gens vous
connaissent les gens connaissent
l'extrême gauche mais ils savent pas à
quoi ça correspond exactement
non mais vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure
je crois que ce qu'on appelle
aujourd'hui l'extrême gauche on pourrait
presque l'appeler la gauche dans la
mesure où la gauche fait une politique
de droite je veux dire c'est à dire que
c'est un courant politique avec
plusieurs organisations la plus connue
les plus connues c'est lui de ouvrières
et la lie communiste révolutionnaire
c'est à dire qu'on se bat pour un
changement réel de société on pense que
jusqu'ici on a fait que du replâtrage il
y a eu beaucoup de mouvements sociaux
dans l'histoire il y a eu le Front
populaire il y a eu la Libération il y a
eu mai 68 mais chaque fois il faut
commencer parce que on s'attaque pas aux
racines je veux dire de tout ce qu'on
peut déplorer de tout ce qui aujourd'hui
nous met en colère
maintenant que les socialistes ont admis
l'économie de marché maintenant que les
communistes depuis Robert Hue se sont
recensés de marché enfin bon c'est les
poupées russes est-ce que vous êtes pour
la révolution
qui est un peu l'image classique c'est à
dire on prend tous les fusils des
mitraillettes on va prendre à tous les
réverbères un patron incurer un adjudant
et non ça c'est ridicule des gens qui
pensent ça mais ils s'en fout non je
crois que la révolution faut le prendre
au vrai sens du terme c'est à dire un
changement radical pour révolutionner le
fonctionnement de cette société comment
vous allez faire parce que vous êtes
présentés au présidentiel on pourrait
penser que soit évidemment on prend des
curés au Réverbère des patrons et comme
on est de le dire soit vous présentez au
présidentiel et vous êtes élu et une
fois que vous êtes président de la
République effectivement vous faites la
révolution je dirais d'une façon
pacifique et légale mais en 69 vous avez
eu 1,05% des voix et en 74 035 donc vous
n'êtes pas prêt d'être présent de la
République donc comment vous allez la
faire votre évolution j'ai pas fait de
coup d'état non moi je crois que ce que
vous appelez la révolution c'est à dire
un changement radical de société
possible que quand des millions de gens
le veulent imaginez que vous ayez été
élu en 69 en 74 si j'étais président
Gérard imaginez qu'est-ce que vous
feriez si vous étiez président de la
République d'abord je crois qu'on n'est
pas comme ça élu président de la
République s'il y a pas un grand
mouvement derrière mais moi je crois
qu'il y a des urines médias à prendre
par exemple qui sont pendrier si vous
étiez président de la République à la
première mesure première interdire tous
les licenciements des entreprises qui
font du profit je crois il faut pas être
révolutionnaire scandalisé devant un
type comme Michelin je remercie parce
qu'ils mettent dans ma propagande intime
comme Michelin qui annonce fièrement
j'ai fait 10% de profits mais
actionnaires veulent 15% de rendement je
vire 10% de mes ouvriers ça interdire
faut interdire ce genre de licenciement
avec des arguments comme ça ça peut
marcher
il y a une deuxième mesure par exemple
immédiate vous avez des millions de gens
aujourd'hui on plaisante en Smart c'est
bien de se marrer d'ailleurs un peu mais
enfin qui sont en dessous des minima
sociaux qui vivent ou survivent avec
2000 3000 francs par mois moi je pense
qu'il faut augmenter de 1500 francs tout
de suite tous les minimas sociaux en
tous ces trucs là c'est assez
vous êtes pour le retour de la
camarguaise par exemple ou pas sans
problème quelle est la différence avec
Arnette Laguiller vous êtes trop de ski
tous les deux skis pour beaucoup de gens
c'est pas trop ce que ça veut dire
mais moi je n'ai pas tellement ce terme
parce que c'est il y a pas de cul de la
personnalité je crois que Trotski qui a
été un des leader révolution russe a
joué à son époque un rôle très éminent
justement pour montrer que ce qui se
passait sous Staline en Union soviétique
c'était une caricature sanglante et nous
justement on a rompu avec ce qui a été
le stalinisme s'écrime le goulag pour
montrer que le communisme et ça se lit
maintenant les mots ils sont un peu
c'est pas du tout ça c'est c'est
exactement l'inverse quelle est la
différence non là on a une différence
d'avril de lutte des classes elle vous
accuse de dérive petite bourgeoise ah
c'est pas grave si vous savez la formule
latine puis benehamas bene castigatte
bien
qui parle latin et l'autre suédoise
c'est ça l'avantage avec eux
si c'est la même chose sur les points
essentiels j'entends les points
essentiel on est d'accord c'est pour ça
qu'on fait des élections ensemble et par
exemple notre caractéristique c'est
qu'on est la seule force de gauche à pas
être gouvernement et être fier de pas
être gouvernement et même d'être
comptabilité
on n'a pas la même pratique pas le même
fonctionnement on n'a pas la même
pratique quotidienne par exemple
ouvrière a une vision de la politique
uniquement limitée aux usines nous on
pense qu'aujourd'hui bien sûr lui dans
les entreprises très importantes mais ce
qu'on fait il faut être avec les
sans-papiers il faut être dans la lutte
des femmes avec la Marche mondiale des
femmes il faut aujourd'hui se battre
pour tous les avec toutes les luttes
écologiques comme Erika toutes les
batailles qui sont venaient moins cher
ils sont plus ouvriers riches je veux
dire à mon avis c'est le désaccord qu'on
peut avoir c'est peut-être une pratique
plus limitée sur le fond on a beaucoup
de points communs sinon ça passe 1999
avez fait une liste commune d'ailleurs
avec Lutte Ouvrière pour les européennes
et vous avez obtenu mais ça marche déjà
mieux quand vous êtes une île vous avez
fait 5.2 et oui c'est pas mal les
Européens alors beaucoup de gens c'est
pas mal peut-être en tous les cas vous
vous avez été lu au Parlement européen
est-ce que vous irez ensemble au
municipal avec Aretha Guy en 2001
j'espère on va voir moi j'espère qu'il y
aura un accord pour résumer tout ce que
vous le dites là c'est pas la révolution
avec un grand air un jour c'est tous les
jours sur des points très précis de la
vie quotidienne révolutionnaire le terme
comme ça d'ailleurs c'est très marrant
c'est quand vous demandez aux gens
est-ce que vous êtes révolté le mot
révolte fait peur je me rappelle Jojo
vieux combattant encore il y a 30 40 ans
la révolte c'était les anarchistes avec
les cheveux en couleur ça foutait la
toute alors la révolution telle que nous
on l'entend c'est à dire un changement
de société au contraire c'est donner un
contenu positif à la règle il faut qu'on
avance parce que sinon
il est intéressant de secret
vous ça vous fait rien vous avez le
public
là le public qui quand on met les gens
souffrent la légende invités ils
m'ouvrir
bien alors à lacrivine vous êtes né en
1941 d'un père de dentiste milieu juif
intello de gauche et alors il vous est
arrivé une histoire extraordinaire un
jour dans l'appartement vous étiez avec
votre mère et votre frère jumeau parce
qu'un incrédine a un frère jumeau
extraordinaire vous êtes donc dans vos
berceaux tous les deux avec votre frère
faux jumeaux Hubert la Gestapo débarque
dans l'appartement donc en étant pas 42
à peu près et les gens de la Gestapo
disent enfin les les
beaux enfants et repartent est-ce que
cette histoire est vraie moi je me
rappelle plus mais c'est ce que ma mère
m'a raconté parce que mon père se
cachait comme tous les Juifs à Paris
donc il n'était pas à la maison et c'est
ce que ma mère a raconté je crois pas
qu'elle a menti c'est incroyable cette
histoire ça peut arriver d'avoir deux
types de la Gestapo comme ça il y a eu
des d'autres enfants comme ça qui sont
pas l'histoire oui en plus ils ont dit
de beaux enfants je dis pas vous êtes
les
est-ce que c'est vrai que c'est cette
chance Limère comme ça dans votre vie
vous allez c'est du recul la dérision de
l'humour parce que finalement tout ce
que vous vivez depuis l'âge de 1 an
c'est durable
[Musique]
quand même dans 57 il y avait déjà eu
Budapest en 57 156 Budapest vous revenez
en disant tout va bien la preuve c'est
qu'en 59 vous rentrez à l'Union des
étudiants communistes et aux parties
communistes français est-ce que c'est
pas bizarre d'être là dans l'URSS 157 et
de rester communiste en revenant est-ce
que c'est pas excusez-moi Alain vous
allez répondre mais est-ce que c'est pas
un peu comme c'est ces artistes français
qui allaient en 37 38 39 dans
l'Allemagne nazie qui revenait en disant
tout va bien là-bas j'avais 16 ans je
crois que c'est très important et à 16
ans je veux dire j'étais invité au
festival de la jeunesse qui était une
espèce de de festival de poudre aux yeux
mais où il y avait des dizaines de
milliers de jeunes qui venaient on était
servis comme des rois et on nous a fait
voir ce qu'ils ont voulu nous faire voir
je veux dire à 16 ans en plus il faut
bien comprendre c'est que le stalinisme
a été quelque chose d'épouvantable on
est bien placé pour le savoir
mais ce que je veux dire c'est que
beaucoup de gens à adhérents Parti
communiste dont moi pas parce que on
était stalinien au sens on adorait un
tyran c'est parce qu'on a cru
malheureusement que Staline c'était
socialyse c'était la Révolution
d'Octobre c'était l'émancipation et du
coup sinon on comprendrait pas pourquoi
des millions d'ouvriers bien sûr et on
adhéré aux parties communistes c'était
pas pour aller à une saloperie c'est il
pensait vraiment une cause progressiste
et c'est après assez vite c'est pas pour
me vanter je suis resté au PC mais en 66
d'être viré oui vous êtes viré alors je
sais pas très bien ce que ça veut dire
vous expliquer pour travail
fractionnelle anti-partie ça veut dire
quoi ça bah à l'époque c'était le Parti
communiste et un des plus staliniens ils
le reconnaît maintenant il a fallu du
temps j'étais dirigeants des étudiants
incomisés à la Sorbonne on était assez
nombreux ça a été 600 à l'époque et on a
à la fois commencé à contester le le
stalinisme bien à l'époque dès qu'on
contestait on était foutu à la porte
alors en 68 bah vous avez la preuve que
finalement une révolte est possible dans
un pays capitaliste moderne avancé vous
avez aussi la preuve que les parties de
gauche ne peuvent pas vraiment prendre
le pouvoir parce que ni le PC ni le PS à
l'époque malgré Charléty ont voulu
prendre le pouvoir mais ce que ce que je
je crois effectivement c'est que la
gauche voulait dans le pouvoir sur ce
qui va pouvoir qui venait de la rue et
les ouvriers ont suivi les étudiants
comme parce que c'était des nouvelles
formes de lutte depuis 30 ans c'était
Bastille République République Bastille
les défilés là ils sont aperçus qu'avec
un mouvement un peu plus radical massif
le gouvernement commençait reculer mais
quand le problème du pouvoir se poser ça
c'est une autre paire de manche et à
justifier confiance niaggiasma ni à
conbénite d'ailleurs qu'ils ont quand on
voit ce qu'ils sont devenus qu'ils ont
parlé alors deux hommes de droite qui a
compris il y a deux hommes de droite qui
ont compris jusqu'où le PC n'irait
jamais c'est de Gaulle qui emporte la
mise en balançant la carotte des
élections et c'est Mitterrand donc vous
qualifiez au passage d'hommes de droite
qui lui fait le programme commun pour
casser le Parti communiste et vous à ce
moment-là vous fondez la Ligue
communiste révolutionnaire alors on va
parler d'aujourd'hui vous êtes députés
européens et vous parlez du du Parlement
européen c'est un peu inquiétant ce que
vous dites vous dites d'abord
l'hémicycle du Parlement européen est
vide sauf le premier jour quand il y a
les télé hein vous dites que par contre
c'est très bizarre parce que l'hémicycle
est vide mais les tribunes sont parce
que le Parlement européen c'est un
circuit touristique absolument il y a
des cartes qui arrivent c'est une
demi-heure de visite à l'écart des
lycées des collèges il y a le buveur de
vierge bavarois il y a les fleuristes je
veux dire ça ça vient de tout partout et
on reste une demi-heure et il voit un
hémicycle vide mais ça gagne ça gagne du
blé des européen c'est pas mal
oui
c'est le salaire d'un député français
c'est 35000 francs mais il y a des
impôts là-dessus puis alors après il y a
tout le reste des animaux 60
000 francs pour payer les assistants
c'est une caricature de démocratie et ça
explique pourquoi l'Europe tout le monde
s'en fout alors que alors qu'il s'y
prend des décisions je veux dire on a 15
personnes qui dirigent 300 millions de
de le fameux conseil que c'est pas le
Parlement qui dirige c'est le conseil on
a 15 personnes non élu qui qui font la
pluie et le beau temps qui peuvent
privatiser la Poste etc mais pour 370
millions de personnes et nous on est
là-dedans un peu dépendantes on abuse un
peu la galerie on a un peu de pouvoir
mais pas en fait des sketchs des trucs
comme ça on pourrait maintenant
on est quatre en séance celui qui va
parler qui veut pas être à la bourre
celui qui parle c'est une minute en
général ou deux minutes et puis celui
qui a parlé moi je reste toujours 5
minutes quand j'ai parlé une minute par
politesse qui va parler donc en général
on est quand même 5 alors que sont
devenus vos amis gauchistes là de
l'époque là parce que Serge Julie par
exemple le patron de libération mais il
va bien vous dites il me donnait
toujours il était toujours le plus
prompt à me faire des cours de moral
politique aujourd'hui vous trouvez qu'il
a tourné comment il a tourné peut-être
pas dans le bon sens mais ça va lui il
voulait prendre le pouvoir en 68 plutôt
par les armes parce qu'il était Maui etc
là il a pris le pouvoir d'un canard très
pacifiquement c'est plus le même c'est
pas qu'on puisse dire bon bah ça va son
journal marche bon comme Bendit alors
vous dites qu'il est plus pour la
dictature du prolétariat mais qu'il est
en revanche pour la dictature des
marchés
au Parlement européen avec moi il a
gardé de beau reste sur le racisme
anti-racisme l'anti rachis mais il y a
pas de problème mais lui-même le
reconnaît il a changé il est devenu
libéral maintenant il est pour
libéralisme mais pas en cause le capital
et le Canada drive de ce qu'il était en
68 oui on peut dire ça comme ça sans
faire de pub tu veux qu'on rentre et mal
là
non d'accord
dites-moi vous alors est-ce que vous
attendez pas pour conclure là-dessus
est-ce que vous attendez pas un petit
peu la révolution comme les monarchistes
attendent la restauration c'est-à-dire
est-ce que finalement vous êtes pas là
en disant j'attends là vous connaissez
votre surnom quoi vous savez comment on
vous appelle quand même appelé comme ça
qui a dit ça c'est pas vrai
mais pas du tout
j'avance lentement comme un vieux
glacier ça c'est beau c'est joli non
mais moi j'entends pas la révolution
comme les royalistes parce qu'à mon avis
les royalistes ils peuvent atteindre
longtemps deuxièmement j'attends pas la
révolution mais j'espère que petit à
petit à travers toutes les luttes qu'on
mène aujourd'hui on va arriver un jour
un grand mouvement qui va changer
radicalement cette semaine
toujours ah bah oui mais sinon je
militerai pas je veux dire moi je milite
pas parce que pour avoir un siège parce
que je peux un politicien j'ai des
convictions ça fait tout drôle
aujourd'hui je suis pas le seul
heureusement j'ai des convictions depuis
20 ans 40 ans et quand je vois la
situation autour de nous je vois pas
pourquoi je changerai je pense qu'on a
encore plus de raison de se révolter
aujourd'hui qu'en 68 les riches sont
plus en plus riches et les pauvres il y
avait pas de chômage il y avait pas le
peigne il y avait pas de tchernobylle
hein beaucoup hein
[Musique]
Zelda
motivé
[Musique]
c'est bien ça ah elle est trop classe
super groupe bien alors on va passer
l'interview nul
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est fini
bien alors l'interview nul vous allez
voir c'est très très con c'est normal ça
s'appelle comme ça donc sinon ça
s'appellerait pas l'interview nul voilà
est-ce que vous préfériez Hitler ou
Staline j'en préfère aucun mais on
compare pas donc
je choisis certainement pas Hitler
d'accord
tiens voilà imaginez que vous croyez la
réincarnation vous préféreriez vous
réincarner en Giscard Balladur au
Raymond Barre
je préfère pas être un cas ah non non
vous avez pas me répondre ça à chaque
fois c'est interdit
Giscard Balladur ou bar voilà c'est un
jeu
parce que moi je ferai rire les gens ah
oui d'accord sympa je vous demande de
vous arrêter
bien
vous donnez plus de circonstances
atténuantes écoutez bien elle est
compliqué celle-là à des vieux qui se
tapent des jeunes ou à des jeunes qui
tapent sur des vieux des jeunes qui
tapent sur des vieux ils ont plus se
content cette nuit
qui se tape des jeunes qu'un jeune qui
tape sur un vieux d'accord
entre pas de sexe et pas manger pendant
10 ans vous choisiriez quoi
compliqué camarades
parce que si vous mangez pas pendant 10
ans toute manière il y aura pas de sexe
dialectique toujours alors imaginez
qu'on soit au sport d'hiver tous les
deux dans un chalet bloqué par la neige
moi je meurs de faim on a plus rien à
manger je meurs de faim et vous vous
êtes avec moi à manger vous commencez
par quoi
le cerveau le cerf mais je ne dirais pas
pourquoi
non non le cerveau le cerveau alors il
est obligé de partir sur une île déserte
à l'imprévine vous préféreriez partir
avec un mec très beau ou une fille très
laide
du tout du tout pour moi d'accord non
pour moi non plus alors un ami débarque
à l'improviste chez vous ce qui vous
ferait le plus honte qui découvre sur la
table de nuit le livre de Claire Chazal
ou un godemichet
il y en a un qui est un outil de plaisir
paraît-il le livre de l'autre qui est
bon enfin bref donc oui non plus plutôt
le livre de Claire Chazal vous préfériez
qu'il voit le livre de Claire Chazal que
le godemichet
alors on va voir si vous avez bon coeur
est-ce que vous échangeriez votre
paralysie générale vous serez paralysé
toute votre vie pour qu'il y ait plus de
famine en Éthiopie
je dirais non parce que c'est le reste
est mensonger ouais donc je me battrai
pour qu'il y a plus de famille Éthiopie
pour ça faut pas être pratique
pour empêcher la famille
mais tu sens le mec a discuté avec ses
copains pendant des années comme ça très
bien
regarder
[Musique]
et voilà j'accueille maintenant maître
Gilbert Collard
super Collard bonsoir bonsoir tout le
monde parle de vous mais je vous avertis
si vous parlez trop parce que vous êtes
avocat bon c'est ce qui va vous arriver
j'entends du soir au matin les mêmes
voilà donc chaque fois que vous
entendrez ça vous vous tirez c'est clair
c'est comme Immo Vrigny pour un clean il
aime il m'ouvrini c'est ça le problème
alors on commence on parle de vous pour
beaucoup de sujets d'abord l'affaire de
la mémorel hein la morale contre les
Guignols
la remise en liberté possible de Sid
Ahmed redzala le tueur présumé du Calais
Vintimille qui est incarcéré au Portugal
depuis le 11 janvier 2000
vos réactions sur la volonté ou le désir
du juge Laurence vichnievski de passer
la main
laurent-juissiers qui est en charge avec
Eva Joly du dossier Elf dans lequel est
impliqué Roland Dumas alors le procès
d'humain alors là quand même le procès
du mât est reporté oui mais vous vous
êtes l'avocat de devierge en cours donc
vous êtes dans le coup du report ah non
pas du tout non non c'est pas Christine
de vierge en cours qui est malade c'est
Renaud Dumas et c'est pas contagieux
donc vous pensez qu'il sera jugé un jour
au lendemain
il faut espérer il faut l'espérer
je crois qu'il est quand même pas aussi
âgé que Papon oui donc il pourrait juger
bien est-ce que vous croyez au passage
comme ça qu'on va retrouver Alfred
sirène
non je sais pas parce qu'il y a plein de
gens comme ça
on a beaucoup de mal à le retrouver oui
c'est vrai peut-être qu'il passe
inaperçu peut-être si ça la discrétion
c'est marrant la justice alors on
commence avec la mémorel on la mémorale
faut dire nos amis qui connaîtriez pas
l'histoire tout le monde la connaît pas
il a eu un procès pour pédophilie viol
de mineur
et les Guignols ont brocardé
votre trait médiatique défense de
pas médiatique du tout non non je n'ai
pas fait une seule intervention pendant
tout le procès donc les Guignols ont
regardé votre défense de la mémorel sont
payés la mémorelle voilà bon vous vous
êtes énervé Alain de grève le patron des
programmes de Canal+ a déclaré en
arrière reçu sauf que le 4 mai c'était
au tribunal de Cusset dans dans l'Allier
là il a reçu vous vous demandez à un
franc la bémorale il demande un million
de francs c'est plus cher qu'est-ce qui
veut se payer des michetons en prison
bah ça doit être très cher en prison ça
doit être très cher alors vous vous
dites que le fait que les Guignols vous
dites le fait que les Guignols se sont
moqués de la mémorelle ce soit moqué de
votre défense de la démoral avant le
procès de la mémorelle ou d'ordition
Sigma et poursuivi je veux dire que
c'est une parodie achat vous dites que
c'est une parodie achat qui fusil la
présomption d'innocence
vous croyez alors sérieusement si les
Guignols c'était pas moqué de lui il
aurait pas pris 10 ans non mais le
problème n'est pas là dire ce qui est ce
qui est insupportable c'est que le
bouffon l'humoriste bon en général il
tape sur les gens puissants sur ceux qui
sont en situation de se défendre qui qui
ont du répondant bon là on a fait un
type qui comparé dans une cour d'assises
croyez moi c'est pas marrant bon qui
risque la réclusion criminale à
perpétuité et pendant toute la semaine
où il est jugé il y a c'est c'est ça le
mecs qui viennent tous les soirs
présenter la mémorelle comme encore cité
contenté de le présenter comme un
pédophile mais il est présente comme un
zoophile bon et il se servent de moi
pour le présenter comme un zoophile bon
alors ce qui fait que ça l'effet
contrairement à ce qu'on pourrait croire
c'est que le matin dans la salle
d'audience les gens en parler bon et on
a entendu on a entendu des jurés en
parler alors je veux dire que bon vous
pensez que ça peut les influencer j'en
sais rien mais en tout cas quand on a un
peu un peu un peu d'honnêteté on se paie
pas la peau d'un mec pendant qu'il passe
en cours d'assise voilà je veux il y a
pas un humoriste de de de au Grand cœur
qui n'est jamais fait il faut que ce
soit Garcia qui est un mec plein de
haine qui règle des comptes personnelles
et ça je pourrai en parler si vous le
voulez qui puisse qui qui qui se permet
de ça quoi voilà bon c'est tout bon moi
j'ai demandé un franc si je le gagne si
je gagne ce franc j'en ferai un très
beau porte-clé voilà
la demande est à hauteur de l'idée qu'on
se fait du préjudice alors le résultat
du procès que vous entendez la bémorer
les vous contre les Guignols sera rendu
le 8 juin
alors l'affaire Rezala c'est les donc
les parents de Corinne caillot qui a été
assassiné à coup de couteau dans la nuit
du 13 au 14 décembre
1999 dans le Calais Vintimille
effectivement donc il s'est réfugié au
Portugal et au Portugal il y a pas de
convention de c'est plus compliqué enfin
disons que le Portugal ne reconnaît pas
la réclusion à perpétuité donc ils
disent à la France si c'est pour le
mettre en prison à perpétuité on vous le
rend pas et il y a une possibilité que
il soit remis en liberté tout simplement
donc vous vous êtes là vous êtes
l'avocat de la famille caillot il y a eu
trois meurtres la famille caillot
on va de d'étonnement en étonnement dans
cette affaire bon d'abord quand on
localise monsieur Rezala comme étant le
présumé coupable avec quand même des
certitudes qui ne sont pas définitives
résumé
répétons-le bon en s'étonne qu'il n'y
ait pas un mandat d'arrêt délivré tout
de suite à vocation nationale ce qui
fait que Rezala vient à Marseille les
journalistes arrivent chez ses parents
avant lui mais les policiers arrivent
après le déjà
première étonnement ensuite on apprend
que malgré le filet paraît-il un
franchissable d'interpols il est en
Espagne
enfin on apprend que malgré le filet
infranchissable d'Interpol il est au
Portugal
et là on apprend que l'article 11 de la
convention d'extradition européenne
exige c'est rédiger du temps ou la peine
de mort exister dans certains états et
pas dans d'autres qu'il y ait adéquation
des peines c'est-à-dire que le pays dont
on réclame qui livre la personne qu'il
détient doit avoir la même pénalité que
le pays qui réclame la personne bon or
la le Portugal depuis la Révolution des
oeillets ne connaît plus la réclusion
criminelle apérité la France connaît la
réclusion criminelle à perpétuité avec
cependant une période de sûreté de 30
ans le verrou de 30 ans
le Portugal peut quand même ordonner
l'extradition à condition qu'il était
garanti que la peine ne sera pas
perpétuelle voilà au point où on en est
si on applique la Convention européenne
d'extradition il ne peut pas être
extraordinaire voilà vous ce que vous
dites vous dites que d'abord on a rien
fait pour récupérer redzala tant qu'il
était en France et en Espagne il faut
quand même qu'on nous explications
donc vous vous dites que if il faut
nommer une commission d'enquête
parlementaire et puis la deuxième chose
que vous dites on arrive à faire
l'Europe des fromages je dis voilà et ça
voilà bon vraiment
quand on voit mais là vraiment on est
dans le dans le concrètement
ses parents pour qu'ils disent enfin
comment on n'a pas pris le temps depuis
de d'uniformiser la loi pénale
européenne on la fait en matière
d'abuste bien sociaux en matière de
fromage de fromage bon et on l'a pas
fait pour ce qui est de l'extradition
des criminels Alain crever une boutique
quelque Parlement européen est-ce que
vous pensez pas qu'il serait temps
d'uniformiser c'est à dire dans tous les
domaines il n'y a pas harmonisation
c'est une robe qui a été fait sur le
plan économique avec des critères
économiques sur tout le reste par
exemple je fais partie de la commission
des libertés il y a aucune art c'est
valable pour les sans-papiers les
immigrés etc il y a aucune harmonisation
du fric quoi
il y en a des sujets avec vous le sujet
suivant c'est Laurence vichenetzky donc
qui est avec Eva Joly qui est magistrat
juste d'instruction alors dans la croix
elle dit qu'elle dit qu'elle en a marre
elle dit que c'est ce qu'on appelle la
tentation de Venise pour reprendre le
titre d'un livre d'un homme politique
autrefois célèbre donc elle elle dit
qu'elle en a marre et elle dit surtout
ça c'est beaucoup plus grave elle dit
qu'elle subit des pressions et donc
elles sont à s'en aller donc si on a
plus d'évasion
c'est les deux seuls ils sont pas
nombreux qu'est-ce qui va traquer bon
alors là l'angle de bois ou l'angle de
vérité langue de vérité ici langue de
bois c'est mon dieu c'est de femmes sont
admirables on nous les enlève elle qui
depuis des années conduisent un combat
elle vient nous dire STOP j'arrête le
match je fais l'objet de pression je
désire quand même un petit poste de
procureur dans la Communauté européenne
quand même ce qui est pas un petit poste
voilà donc ce que vous dites ce soir
c'est elle en a trop dit ou elle en a
trop dit ou pas assez quand on est
magistrat on peut pas on peut pas bannir
au public j'ai été victime de pression
et ne pas dire de qui d'autant plus que
représentant Christine de dijoncourt moi
je serai je suis vachement intéressé oui
à savoir qui a fait dépression
alors elle risque rien de le dire alors
très bien donc maintenant Gilbert
Collard on va passer à peu près
le temps d'aller chez le coiffeur
[Applaudissements]
comment ça vous plaise
aux yeux le ciel bleu
papa il y a plein de montant il y a
plein de gens
je me suis demandé d'où venait votre
votre bagou
j'ai découvert en fait que votre père
était Camelot du roi c'était notaire
votre père
et donc il était Camelot du roi il avait
Moras comme client d'ailleurs et quand
vous étiez petit vous en ami de un ami
et quand vous étiez petit non mais j'ai
cherché pourquoi vous aviez cette ce
côté vindicatif et vous lisiez Léon 2D
quand vous étiez petit ah oui mais
Alphonse Daudet a été le secrétaire de
mon arrière-arrière-grand-père qui dont
il a fait sur lequel il a fait un
pamphlet terrible qu'il intitulé le
nabab ah oui ah c'est lui c'est lui oui
et c'est comme ça que nous avons eu des
liens avec la famille Daudet alors donc
bizarrement là je me tourne vers Kevin
parce que donc père Camelot du roi lui
nourrit avec
Mestre de Mestre avec Daudet etc hein je
lui ai 18 ans vous rentrez chez les
francs-maçons alors ça c'est incroyable
donc ce retournement est dû à quoi parce
que écoutez je suis je suis entré à
l'âge de
8 ans chez les Pères Maristes
des excuses peux-tu écrivez
j'en suis sorti j'ai fait deux évasions
je les ai loupé j'en suis sorti par la
grande porte par la lassitude des pères
à l'âge de 17 ans
et puis je fais mes études tout seul tu
dois etc bon et
quand j'ai eu l'âge de 18 19 ans
j'ai rogné tous tout ça alors je vais
vous dire pourquoi j'ai les cheveux
longs parce que chez les père Marie on
nous tendait
je plaide tous les tous les vendredis on
était on avait on avait les cheveux
coupés à la tondeuse électrique
donc à 18 ans Gilbert Collard vous
devenez franc-maçon à 25 vous êtes
vénérable de votre loge les vieux amis
c'est exact et vous êtes exclus à 26
pourquoi je suis exclu avant vous partez
ah non je suis pas parti non non j'ai
j'ai présidé pendant un an et puis j'ai
eu un vrai dégoût de la direction
et donc j'ai rendu comme on dit le
maillet mais je suis toujours
franc-maçon non non c'est une erreur et
aujourd'hui vous êtes quoi alors vous
êtes anarchiste
vous êtes un artiste chrétien vous êtes
situationniste vous êtes quoi
aujourd'hui je suis je suis chrétien
très sincèrement et je me sens
profondément libertaire j'aime la
liberté c'est la raison pour laquelle je
suis pas du tout le genre de type à dire
les humoristes faut leur couper la
langue les faire etc bien est-ce que
vous pensez pas que vous êtes un peu
surexposé médiatiquement que oui
je vous pose des questions alors vous
avez des succès quand même j'ai essayé
de trouver vos succès c'est dur non
parce que à force de regarder les
Guignols
pourquoi pourquoi c'est arrivé ça parce
que je peux vous raconter maintenant ça
va vite vous savez que j'ai fait que
j'ai fait pour le papa d'un petit
trisomique un procès intime oui bon avec
qui on est réconcilié qui s'est comporté
une manière
formidable formidable bon mais je ne
savais pas quand j'ai fait le procès que
l'auteur du sketch était Gaccio c'est
vrai bon et puis on me raconte alors le
procès a lieu l'arrangement avec mimsit
n'était pas encore organisé et des amis
me disent tu sais mon pote tu vas avoir
ta marionnette je t'attendais pourquoi
il me dit mais Garcia ne supporte pas
que tu fasses un procès à teamsit qui
l'oblige à retirer les cassettes il dit
que tu lui prends du blé
et il va te faire payer le coup voilà
alors je trouve que si c'est ça la
démocratie médiatique c'est en réalité
des règlements de comptes au coin des
rues fascistes très bien alors j'en
étais à vous succès de Me coupez pas je
coupe plus donc en gros je ne suis pas
chaud
donc avec Pierrette Le Pen vous êtes
l'avocat de Pierrette Lefebvre vous
étiez l'avocat de Pierrette Le Pen
Jean-Marie Le Pen dit en parlant de sa
femme qu'elle fasse des ménages et vous
vous la faites enfin vous la faites vous
faites en sorte qu'elle pose à poil dans
Playboy je le coupe
vous avez fait condamné c'est lui non
mais c'est pour ça il a pas il a pas
fait des trucs bien vous avez fait
condamné Bernard Tapie dans l'affaire
omva vous défendiez bernesse oui
Virenque il a jamais craqué non pour
raconter ce qu'on veut mais il a jamais
craqué donc vous avez été beaucoup hein
moi non plus vous avez beaucoup attaqué
mais finalement
vous avez quand même quelques virenques
c'est l'exemple même d'un mec qui les
prix de l'ado pour qu'il n'ait pas pris
on s'en fout en tous les cas il a pas
craqué je crois qu'il faut tenir bon il
faut tenir voilà il faut pas céder à la
pression médiatique
après commissaire Navarro après l'instit
après docteur Silvestre Cordier jugé
Commissaire Moulin Madame le Proviseur
découvrez le nouveau héros récurrent
Maître Collard avocat j'ai ici une
enveloppe
qui confondation
et je suis tombé Maître Collard avocat
la première série diffusée sur toutes
les chaînes de télévision mais monsieur
Amar jugez vous-même Aurore le portrait
tout craché d'Yves Montand c'est sa
fille
Maître Collard avocat
même sur Kev Adams ne sait jamais dopé
jamais oui voilà l'insulte mon plein
Maître Collard avocat le héros récurrent
déjà présent sur les chaînes airbn et
bientôt sur Paris Première Canal Jimmy
MCM Teva Eurosport Télétoon canal
satellite TPS internet c'est des Roms
PlayStation boîte de vache qui rit
attention toute ressemblance avec un
avocat qui plaiderait dans un tribunal
dans le but de gagner les procès de ses
clients ne seraient que pure coïncidence
[Applaudissements]
c'est toujours quand c'est l'autre qu'on
rigole mais ce que je veux faire
observer c'est que je pourrais m'en
amuser de ce truc si elle n'est pas
cette idée derrière de règlement de
compte ça qui m'emmerde moi c'est que je
pensais que c'est l'histoire du
trisomique je sais mais il il a raconté
ça m'a été répété bon et puis et puis
quelques après le jour du procès est
trisomique il a fait un sketch de la
même manière bon au moment maintenant
et vous c'est vraiment la guerre parce
qu'il a déclaré Bruno Gaccio qui est
l'auteur principal des Guignols il a dit
un jour dans son plateau de TV plus
parce qu'ils étaient plus avec amour
vous avez plus connard comme avocat ça
tombe bien vous avez une chance de
gagner
un truc se débarrasse de lui ils ont une
chance de devenir un peu plus
respectable ceci étant la mère de ordre
SAR euh a déclaré en parlant de vous
quand même que parce que là j'ai fait
tous les succès maintenant je fais un
peu hein c'est comme au tribunal
maintenant la mère de rendre ça a
déclaré Collard toute façon la seule
chose qui l'intéresse c'est son image
dès qu'il a eu le rapport d'autopsie la
balancé un hebdo il est toujours là pour
la presse nous quand on l'appelle il est
jamais libre il a essayé de dresser ma
fille Aurore contre moi pour son
diffamation et hop tac tac prends ça
dans la gueule voilà
[Musique]
il est comme ça
on n'a pas de raison je veux dire on n'a
pas de raison de se laisser maltraiter
quand on n'a pas tort donc non seulement
elle s'est fait faire une gamine par mon
temps en plus
alors toujours j'ai quand même j'ai
quand même dû assister à
aleximation et alors j'en parle pas de
ça non non alors je me suis je me suis
quand même tapé la mort à
minuit 1h du matin ils ont fait ça la
nuit en plus dites-moi alors on reste
dans l'exhumation c'est un truc gay pour
le samedi soir Carpentras à la
conférence de presse organisée par le
cousin de Félix Germond donc le malheur
vous prétendez détenir les noms
et vous et vous montrez une enveloppe 3
ans après que c'était un skinhead qui
avait fait le coup
d'abord je trouve je suis réconcilié
avec les skinnets de néo-nazis qui ont
des remords 3 ans après à quelques
minutes de la prescription je trouve que
vous pensez que c'est bidon non je me
permettrai pas de dire ça parce mec
attendez puisqu'on parle sérieusement et
comme un mec qu'on a retrouvé avec du
béton autour des pieds dangereux je me
suis battu j'ai pris des coups tout le
monde a dit que c'était la vérité
officielle on l'a cru j'ai pas envie de
reprendre des couples pour rien entre
nous je dis simplement que c'est
extraordinaire qu'un skinhead un néonazi
enfin un type bariolé de croix gammée à
quelques fractions de seconde de la
prescription c'est vrai que ça arrive
attendez c'est moi pas néo-nazi moi
scout
repentir total je vais tout vous dire
bon la France entière la crue j'ai eu je
croyais pas vous
non mais non
je l'ai dit aujourd'hui mais en revanche
en revanche je n'ai jamais jamais
brandit une quelconque enveloppe
contenant le nom de quelques de quelques
qu'est-ce qu'il y avait dans cette
enveloppe mais je n'en sais rien
l'enveloppe on a les on a les images il
suffit de les voir c'est le père germon
qui arrive avec un dossier lors d'une
conférence de presse et qui dit j'ai une
enveloppe à remettre à mon avocat il
sort une enveloppe sur laquelle il y a
écrit de sa main les noms des
profanateurs il me l'attend je la saisie
du bout des doigts
allons-y les photos les photographes les
photographes les photographes
photographie évidemment et après les
Guignols vont dire et c'est là où ils
ont un effet terrible c'est que quand
vous présentez la formation vous
répercutez ce qu'ils ont dit alors que
là
je vous remercie on va parler de votre
bouquin maintenant alors vous publiez un
livre dont on va parler qui s'appelle
Peut-On rire de tout juste
ce bouquin là vous êtes à tout le monde
là
vous dites qui sont dans le sens du vent
médiatique qui suivent les mois de
journalistes vous en prenez Laurent
Ruquier c'est pas très gentil c'est vrai
Laurent Laurent il est dit non mais je
regrette le je regrette vous êtes
réconcilié avec Laurent on est
réconcilié oui vous dites l'ancien
comptable est venu à purer ses comptes
vous êtes vu au Lutetia c'est ça on
s'est vu on a réglé nos ultimes compte
salon Ernest au Lutetia et je l'écris du
reste c'est le seul qui a eu qui a eu le
la courtoisie d'avoir une explication
bon et après je me suis rendu compte que
finalement il y a pas de haine chez lui
bon je croyais qu'il y avait de la haine
la luminosité il y en a pas non mais je
le dis bonjour
parce que je trouve que il a une bon je
trouve qu'il a un humour un peu un peu
un peu constipé voilà on peut constiper
bon je trouve que je trouve qu'il est
vraiment très préoccupé par la merde
un peu oui j'ai oublié de vous poser la
question tout à l'heure bon
cela étant dit il lui arrive d'être très
drôle bon
alors vous dénoncez
le privilège de l'impunité alors peut-on
rire de tout donc effectivement peut-on
rire des trisomiques non je dis non
peut-on rire de dur à four crématoire
donc on peut pas rire de tout non ben
non on peut pas on peut pas Patrick
Sébastien s'en est rendu compte quand il
a fait le sketch cassé du noir casser du
noir bon on ne peut on ne peut pas rire
de tout parce que rire de tout c'est
finalement rire de l'humain vous dites
ma vraie vocation c'était d'être
comédien c'est vrai c'est vrai c'est
vrai vous auriez voulu être comédien je
voulais être comédien je vous posez une
autre question mais Serge j'aimerais
qu'on change un peu la lumière là
Gilbert Collard
est-ce que quand vous dites Gilbert
Collard quand vous dites quand vous
dites Gilbert Collard qu'on vous dites
on ne m'aime pas et je le sais est-ce
que finalement votre problème dans la
vie ça serait pas d'être aimé tout
simplement
je crois que le problème de tous les
êtres humains c'est de n'être pas assez
aimé oui oui je le confesse volontiers
donc c'est pour ça que vous êtes comme
ça peut-être
vous êtes sincère là vous dites la
vérité là on rallume
ça rappelle un peu la vue et les procès
de Moscou vous avez vu hein
n'exagérons rien dit
alors comme votre livre vous dites que
c'est un coup de gueule on va vous faire
une interview dernier coup on ne bouge
pas pendant un jingle
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bien alors dernier coup de gueule
le dernier coup de gueule que j'ai
poussé c'était hier contre qui c'était à
propos de la faire Rezala d'accord
dernier coup de tête dernier coup de
tête qu'est-ce que c'est qu'un coup de
tête c'est un truc une décision qu'on
prend comme ça comme cade il veut
rentrer avec Emma comme ça
mon dernier coup de mon dernier coup de
tête c'était il y a
[Musique]
il y a 15 jours quand j'ai acheté à ma
fille des doubles rideaux un sac je sais
pas
un singe
[Applaudissements]
non elle voulait un sac je suis dans une
boutique avec elle elle a 11 ans et elle
me dit papa ce sac me plaît
et écoutez cher ça m'a ça m'a fait chier
de dépenser une somme importante pour le
responsables mais j'ai pas pu lui
refuser c'est bien c'est bien ça part
d'un bon sentiment dernier coup de poing
d'un coup de poing c'est un vrai coup de
fouet
[Applaudissements]
dernier coup de pub dernier coup de pub
ici ce soir et merci parce que ça vaut
vraiment la peine de venir dernier coup
de foudre dernier coup de foudre
mais en plus c'est vrai moi vous êtes
marrant les mecs quand même en plus
c'est ma femme
dernier coup de bluff
dernier coup de bluff tous les jours cet
après-midi
hier soir bravo
j'accueille maintenant
maintenant une China girl
[Musique]
s
bonsoir
honnêtement c'est pas la LCR que vous
avez des filles comme ça à côté de vous
voir d'habitude il est avec
Jennifer là vous êtes servis ce soir
c'est la révolution ce soir
comment ça va Jennifer
un roman qui s'appelle pourvu que tu
m'aimes
c'est voilà alors
vous êtes né à Abidjan c'est d'abord moi
je fais toujours ça qu'on sache bien à
qui on a affaire comment on fait à la
barde d'ailleurs vous êtes né à Abidjan
d'un père d'origine chinoise en fait
c'est votre c'est votre grand-père qui
est parti de Chine juste avant la
Révolution
il aimait pas la révolution pas vraiment
non
vous trouvez pas est-ce que la
révolution chinoise se trouve grâce à
vos yeux non pas plus que la révolution
russe si
c'est ce qui est arrivé après d'accord
voilà bien
une politique politicien votre mère
était peintre vous êtes arrivés à Paris
à l'âge de 5 ans alors là on s'accroche
Jennifer Kouassi hypokhâgne Cagne
licence maîtrise DEA et vous préparez un
doctorat
sur les auteurs décadents les auteurs de
la fin du 19e siècle les auteurs
alors j'ai été critique littéraire au
Quotidien de Paris vous aviez quel âge à
l'époque
j'avais c'était pendant mes études en
fait je devais avoir
22 ans 23 ans ensuite j'ai travaillé
avec Michel Field au cercle de minuit
ensuite vous l'avez suivi sur Canal
quand il a fait l'hebdo ensuite vous
avez travaillé sur France 2 dans une
émission qui s'appelle thé ou café enfin
je chroniquais les livres
ensuite vous avez fait la cinquième vous
avez été rédacteur en chef de droit
d'auteur ensuite Canal+ vous êtes
retourné à Canal+ et là c'est vous qui
avez programmé les écrivains qui passent
chez Nagui voilà c'est ça comment ça se
passe
je pensais
vous dites à Nagui par exemple voilà je
suggère
et il donne il donne son avis et voilà
et les auteurs sont sur le plateau le
soir
j'ai vu c'est une idée à vous oui est-ce
que vous trouvez que une personne bi a
été bien traité sur le plateau nulle
part ailleurs par rapport à l'immense
auteur qu'il est alors il y a eu il y a
eu évidemment une polémique parce que il
y a eu une bouteille de lait qui est
arrivé sur le plateau bon lancée par les
Robins des Bois enfin je pense que
Hubert Selby étant donné son parcours
il a connu enfin c'est quand même
il a été héroïne
et donc bon une bouteille de lait qui
arrive comme ça sur le plateau ne lui
fait pas forcément peur d'accord alors
on va parler de votre livre donc pourvu
que tu m'aimes chez Grasset je refais
alors c'est l'histoire vous le faites
pas connard
non j'ai une crampe je te rappelle que
tu étais à deux doigts
vous êtes donc vous avez écrit ce
bouquin c'est l'histoire d'une métisse
qui s'appelle Jane qui est né dans une
île qui arrive enfant en France et qui
rencontre un photographe qui s'appelle
un photographe baroudeur qui s'appelle
Lancelot
alors je vais lire parce que je crois
que le plus simple quand on parle de
littérature c'est de lire le plus beau
voyage est celui que l'on fait d'abord
de mon cœur à mon sexe puis un versement
on part alors de ce delta irrigué pour
s'enfoncer vers les méandres de mon âme
c'est ce triangle brun cette brassée de
roseau en eau poissonneuses qui mène à
mes vérités cachées il est le seul à y
avoir accès il me semble donc inutile de
lui raconter ma vie quand il connaît
déjà ce que j'ai de plus intime nous
embauche un coin
c'est pas mal
alors Lancelot vachement beau de parler
comme ça des trucs bras et tout
lancelotes
qui sont les décadents
Jules Laforgue Barbey de révélie
Baudelaire a été un précurseur
donc Lancelot le photographe baroudeur
héros de votre livre que Jane aime
rencontrer aime il l'amène d'abord dans
une boîte et ensuite dans un dans un
resto branché et alors je reprends le
livre page 65 j'avais vaguement honte de
me livrer corps et âme à un homme qui
mettait encore inconnu au matin
mais je m'étais toujours fait confiance
pour reconnaître l'amour quand il
passerait j'avais su le retenir c'est
goûter ma bouche était blessée par sa
barbe qui poussait un peu comme toi
Olivier sa barbe qui repoussait à mesure
que la nuit fait glisser j'avais doit
coller d'un sucre épais comme ce lait
qui coule de certaines plantes
tropicales je pensais au cas où dans ton
blesse les corps pour qu'il saigne en
couple et blanche je pensais aussi à
cette tigresse qui tournait en cage dans
un zoo et cette odeur d'urine et de Ruth
ça y est
je sais pas vous mais je sais pas si
vous fait rire vous créez une ça vous
laisse ça vous laisse deux marbre à
l'incrivine ça un peu oui
parce que selon qu'elle est très sympa
comme ça photographe baroudeur et tout
il est pas si simple parce que en
parlant avec son ami clair Jane découvre
qu'elle a déjà couché avec lui et il
l'amène pas seulement dans des soirées
branchées il a un côté oui il a un côté
très sombre aussi c'est un personnage am
et Jane va découvrir ce qui se passe
livrer corps et âme dans cet amour va
découvrir évidemment l'ambiguïté et
qu'il l'amène quand même dans le drôles
d'endroits
à m'arrêter ils sont à Pigalle lance-le
obligé à m'arrêter devant les affiches
obscène ou des filles jambes écartées et
crouptes tendus s'exposer à la
convoitise des regards etc etc et alors
un jour il a voulu m'entraîner dans une
boutique pour prostituer avec attirail
écoutez bien avec si je vous donnerai
l'adresse avec attirail de tout genre en
tout genre à bout de tentatives ce
samedi là j'ai fini par accepter de me
rendre dans cette boutique
il y avait toutes sortes de colis
fichiers loufoques des barboteuses pour
petite fille vicieuse
des slips innocents qui offraient la
surprise d'une fente incongrue des robes
de latex moulantes comme un gant
chirurgical qui adhéré aux mannequin en
plastique il y avait des fouets des
tétines des chaussures pour fétichisme
qui enfermé le pied dans une prise
ancienne élevée qu'on risquait dans
tomber en se brisant les eaux lance le
voulu que j'ai laissé les robes donc
cette scie cette gêne se retrouve
finalement au début tout va bien et tout
ça puis elle se retrouve vraiment dans
une drôle d'histoire quoi c'est
l'innocence
c'est la tentation de de l'impur et
c'est la découverte d'une sexualité un
peu obscure et c'est la découverte c'est
pas simplement un roman érotique cet
argent de l'amour il s'agit de parler du
corps évidemment on pouvait pas faire
l'économie du corps et d'ailleurs je
pense qu'en ce moment il y a tout un
courant littéraire qui cherche
autobiographique
dis la vérité attention ne m'obligez pas
à faire la question qui tue Jennifer
le graphique sur l'enfance parce que
c'est aussi un moment d'enfance et c'est
peut-être ça
qu'il est photographe
comme vous elle a été élevée par sa
grand-mère comme vous et c'est pas
autobiographique mais surtout l'enfance
c'est le et puis la voix finalement la
voix de cette jeune fille qui s'exprime
c'est l'histoire avant tout d'une femme
qui est une enfance très dure et que
j'ai vécu réellement en effet j'ai une
enfant très difficile parce que j'ai
connu l'exil comme l'héroïne j'ai été
pensionnaire à 5 ans j'ai bon en effet
j'ai vécu avec une grand-mère très
difficile dans une sorte de château qui
partait à vos locaux comme l'héroïne
mais enfin ça s'arrête à peu près là et
c'est pas votre mari
je sors aussi je vis je découvre bon
l'accueil critique a été plutôt plutôt
bon à part à part le Figaro littéraire à
part la Pâques dans le Figaro littéraire
a dit que c'était
comme Arlequin
très drôle c'est que juste après j'ai
reçu beaucoup de lettres de d'admirateur
enfin de lecteurs qui étaient admirateur
admiratif du livre et qui disait cette
critique qui était un peu qui semblait à
force de taper trop fort en tape à côté
m'a donné envie de le lire et donc je
suis un défenseur un animal mais bon
c'est pas pour moi c'est pas c'est pas
forcément une critique trop désagréable
[Musique]
j'avais pas cette chance j'adore cette
j'adore cette chanson elle existe par
David Bowie
on va faire une interview première fois
on bouge pas par un jingle
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous allez puni est-ce qu'on peut
m'apporter le martinet qu'on a acheté à
Pigalle la punition c'est une interview
première fois
vous allez répondre franchement je vais
essayer premier désir
le livre m'a sauvé de de beaucoup de
choses m'a aidé à me construire première
nuit à deux
est-ce que vous vous souvenez de votre
première nuit à deux
un plus un c'est ça
première larme pour un garçon j'ai pas
pleurés
à 22 ans
votre première vraie transgression
sexuelle
à 3 ans première
œdipe c'est ça première fois à plusieurs
je ne dis rien
je ne veux pas que ça se sache c'est
peut-être là en ce moment
où je me déshabille première fois avec
une fille
[Rires]
vous êtes menteuse
un écrivain et par essence non
on m'avait dit on avait dit ces filles
là elles sont difficiles bien vous
restez avec nous
j'accueille maintenant le Molière du
meilleur one man shower tour au Black M
Molière du meilleur one man show lundi
dernier
sur France 2 en direct pour l'homme au
mille visages c'est lui alors
comme les gens connaissent pas tous
encore bien que vous ayez beaucoup de
succès vraiment beaucoup beaucoup de
succès vous étiez à Marigny il a fallu
le prolonger à Mogador mais comme tout
le monde ne vous connaît pas encore on
va regarder ce que vous faites
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
Molière du meilleur one man show art
mille visages à Mogador jusqu'à la
mi-juin bravo bravo c'est magnifique
vraiment c'est extraordinaire justement
la seule question qu'on se pose c'est
comment tu fais il y a un truc
derrière une football tills
80 transformations extraordinaires il y
a le western il y a un truc western ça
n'est plus extraordinaire parce qu'il y
a six personnages qui s'interpellent qui
tire dessus et des fois qui apparaissent
partiellement en même temps ça c'est
assez
en même temps c'est assez extraordinaire
alors vous faites un hommage au cinéma
hollywoodien vous faites qui comme
personnage beaucoup
alors là il y a je suis pas justement tu
voyais la song of music là qui devient
qui devient tué par cycose mais le tueur
de cycose c'est Jane Kelly dancing in
the rain qui devient un Freebox et
engrid ben mathématique qui de quand
c'est par l'avion ça devient King Kong
qui rattrape l'avion et donc une
consistance
qui deviennent extraordinaire oh là là
qui se termine par Elana VEVA tout ça
autour d'une boîte qui tourne et voilà
et qui révèle à chaque fois un nouveau
monde c'est ça parce que l'idée du
metteur en scène c'est que il y a cette
boîte qui tourne qui s'ouvre sur un
nouveau décor comme sur une nouvelle
visage un peu à la fin on dit vraiment
que chacun de nous a sa petite boîte
dans son cœur ou il garde tous ses
souvenirs son monde donc chacun de nous
ça il faut aller le voir alors voilà
maintenant on va voir tous les Black
Eyes le soir de son bonheur de son
triomphe
alors les
nominations
Arturo Brachetti
Laurent Gerra
et jean-Jacques Vanier
[Applaudissements]
est attribué à Arturo Brachetti
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il y a toujours des espions enfin des
menteurs tu sais c'est venir qu'il a
gagné du théâtre j'étais préparé à
sourire gentiment puis quand il
m'appelait
pas préparé le discours donc c'était
encore c'est pas grave personne prépare
jamais rien c'est ridicule
alors le transformer vous êtes un
transformiste le transformiste ça
commence au XVIe siècle ensuite ça a été
repris par la commedia della alors
raconté un peu comment ça a commencé
c'est-à-dire le type qui suit le patron
qui suit son employé l'autre se cache
dans une caisse la base de la chose la
transformisme le premier c'était un
acteur italien c'est sur une place
publique il changeait de masque qui
faisait plusieurs personnes ça peut être
Giovanni Gabriel et le curieux c'est
qu'il avait deux fils donc ils étaient
assis sur le coin de son plateau à la
fin il demandait un petit saut si je
sais pas pour moi c'est pour ces beaux
enfants et le plus grand de ses enfants
c'était scapino donc le plus grand
commun
du 17e siècle donc tu vois ça c'est le
début du transformisme et après il y a
eu effectivement au 19e siècle frigo lui
il m'a plu il y avait tu sais Tabarin
c'était un comique italien qui est sur
le quai de la Seine faisait numéro de
chapeau changer de chapeau beaucoup de
fois moi j'aurais pris ce numéro et je
change 27 fois du chapeau donc c'est une
art ancienne mais très rare parce que
bon et le secret sont maintenus très
très secret justement il y a des gens
que j'ai commencé je ne connaissais pas
j'étais moi aussi chez les prêtre six
ans chez le séminaire j'avais les bonnes
soeurs qui faisaient le maquillage
j'étais terrible alors ce qu'il faut
dire c'est que c'est pas seulement un
défilé de costume votre argent
c'est-à-dire je vais raconter quelque
chose vous avez fait au National à
Londres c'est un ouvrier qui se
transforme en soldat à ce moment-là il
explose et il devient sa mère en noir
qui donc il y a une émotion qui qui est
même au-delà de la surprise
plusieurs fois dans dans un spectacle
parce qu'en Italie je suis produit par
l'État oui je fais des spectateurs des
fois je fais Shakespeare des fois donc
des fois c'est très sérieux et dans la
transformation se devient un moyen
théâtral et cette fois la nationalité je
veux juste ce soldats perdus dans une
usine de bombe et qui il voyait la
guerre encore une fois donc redevenez
soldat et puis pendant qu'il revoyait le
moment où il était blessé il créé
c'est devenu la femme en noir avec une
bougie qui pleurait et là tout le monde
moi il y avait le noir fin première acte
je sortais de scène il y avait pas
d'applaudissement à rien on a raté par
contre les gens ils étaient tellement
surpris qu'à la fin c'était le mélange
de surprise visuel de très belles scènes
alors vous dites c'est très italien de
se changer parce que finalement c'est
pour plaire au dernier conquérant et
c'est vrai que l'Italie a tellement été
occupé que alors vous voulez pas avouer
votre date de naissance
si vous êtes né dans un village à 40 km
de Turin vous étiez un enfant timide
maigre vous étiez nul au football j'ai
pris ma rêve
vous rentrez au séminaire va d'abord le
Petit Séminaire puis après le Grand
Séminaire chez les Salésiens et c'est un
curé donne mantelli qui vous a initié la
magie et vous étiez tellement ressenti
tellement un bon élève qui lui a donné
les clés de son bureau et à Tours il est
allé dans le bureau
business ben fantastique il fait 300
spectacles par année il a adopté ça
enfant au troisième monde et alors quand
vous êtes adolescent votre foi va si
c'est à dire que vous vouliez vous
voulez plus être patte au moment où vous
commencez l'adolescence
vous perdez l'envie d'être pape oui
parce que bon j'avais les clés tu
faisais du sûreté du séminaire tous les
deux jours du séminaire vous étiez
figurant à l'Opéra et là vous connaissez
toute ma vie mais oui mais vous êtes une
vous avez des espions là
c'est intéressant vous dites aujourd'hui
quand on vous parle vous donc vous
faites le mur et aujourd'hui quand on
vous parle de la religion vous dites
j'irai brûler avec le reste de mes amis
donc vous avez bien quitté la religion
là mais tu sais la religion ça suffit
d'avoir un sentiment religieux plus
c'est à la odieux Jéhovah c'est une
relative c'est des hygiène de vie et de
tête c'est tout alors l'opéra évidemment
vous découvrirez un autre univers que le
séminaire
vous découvrez les cantatrices obsédées
sexuelles vous découvrirez le torero
dans la Carmen on va en avoir un prêt de
vous découvrirez si torero mais le vrai
escam au milieu c'était un gros pas
possible sur
un chanteur ténor et nous avons été des
figurantes très bêtes très fines il y
avait des oui et tu sais que les les les
chanteurs de Perray se donnent des
petites coups derrière enfin non
pourquoi mais des petites signes pour
finir la note en même temps sinon
l'autre il y a un qui dure plus
longtemps alors c'est l'autre je me
demandais toujours à finir oui alors ils
font le duo il se touchent des relais
mains ils font
ils donnent une signe et ils finissent
ensemble et alors un jour vous êtes
découvert enfin vous êtes pas découvert
vous êtes déjà connu mais c'est Majax
Gérard Majax
on connaît bien il est sympa et alors il
vous trouvez il va toujours voir les
congrès des magiciens voilà donc lui il
avait mal à la tête les copains italiens
du regard ce numéro avant de partir et
puis ma
douche commune douche commune déjà le
premier jour ça commence bien
bah personne c'était bien parce que
après un succès mondial
même une sitcom pour Hollywood non
maintenant oui c'est le numéro 0 il y a
2 mois et donc
je vais faire les 10 prochains les 10
prochaines avec la Warner Bros avec
[Applaudissements]
on va faire une interview vous avez pas
bouger
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bien on s'appelle lardiview pensez à
quoi là
qu'est-ce que j'ai pensé
je dois charger la voiture un peu
fatiguée vous voulez quoi vous voulez
manger quelque chose ne t'inquiète pas
je vais m'arranger qu'est-ce que la
dernière chose que vous faites le soir
avant de vous coucher
j'ai répondu à mes emails à la dernière
dernière non la dernière dernière c'est
pas ça
le matin quand vous vous voyez dans
votre glace dans votre miroir vous dites
quoi ça
complètement
la salle de bain vous dormez beaucoup
oui je dors 8 9 heures je pense que
c'est juste qu'est-ce que vous
changeriez en vous si vous aviez une
baguette magique en beaucoup de choses
physiques surtout moi vous êtes
vachement bien
écoute Emma il est très bien je trouve
bon il y a son truc sur la tête là bon
mon truc c'est la meilleure chose
quelle est la phrase que vous ne
supportez pas d'entendre
je supporte pas les gens quand ils
parlent des trucs qu'ils ont fait c'est
pas vrai tu vois
le côté du show business que je connais
bien parce que bon je vois plein de gens
où ils veulent des trucs des autres gens
qu'est-ce qui vous énerve le plus chez
vous chez moi où est la chose de vous
que vous ne supportez pas
des fois je m'énerve de pas c'est
méchant avec les autres parce que de
temps en temps il faut
bon et qu'est-ce qui vous énerve le plus
chez moi je vous connais pas encore
est-ce que vous êtes déjà senti le
maître du monde
sûrement tout le monde car il joue un
jeu vidéo Game c'est à ce moment-là
est-ce que vous êtes déjà senti une
ou quoi une ah
c'était le nouveau mot
oui oui oui mec c'est quand vraiment je
dis une grand mensonge quelque chose de
vous sentez une est-ce que
vous préférez draguer ou vous faire
draguer ou draguer est-ce que vous
préférez larguer ou faire larguer
normalement je suis largué
parce que je vais trop vite dans la
drogue
nation vite alors qu'à Paris
comment vous aimeriez mourir moi sur
scène avec une tu vois ce gros lustre
sur la tête par exemple
ça te fait de ça fait des archives pour
les enfants de la télé
Arthur pendant des années il va repasser
nos bouts d'émission
dernière question on doit être réincarné
en quel personnage que vous incarnez sur
scène là
quand j'étais petit je pensais d'être
saint François prêt je sais pas pourquoi
pas de vie simple donc je sais pas
pourquoi vous devriez être un ange oui
je veux j'ai déjà fait plusieurs fois là
je sur scène ça me plaît beaucoup à plus
comme vu que je vole parce que j'ai
plusieurs machines pour voler à la
maison
avec nous
j'accueille maintenant Soren Prévost
bonsoir
il est moche se décore
bonsoir papa
c'était marqué que j'étais à côté de
Mademoiselle
on a lancé un appel au début de
l'émission ça a marché les temps hein
non non non
tu vas pas nous prendre nos gonzesses
aussi tu as déjà pris les moltères
déjà c'est pas bien mais ouais ça c'est
vrai que
Mathilde Seigner tu es pas contente que
vous ayez piqué le Molière de
l'orangeraro ouais je lui croyais toute
sa bagnole elle était remontée
bien alors sereine Prévost oui donc vous
êtes habillé là en Astrid en Astrid la
Brel di Manolo tout à fait le torero
votre spectacle c'est ça c'est un torero
qui pendant une heure se prépare pour la
pour la corrida
[Rires]
après vous ça va deux bonjour les gars
oh il a dû avoir son heure de gloire
chez lui un moment donné et puis là bon
bah il est pas qu'il est minable il est
un peu pétochard il est assez trouillard
quand il voit le steak en face de lui
oui mais enfin bon je pense que tout
torero qui qui sommeille en chacun de
nous a peur quelque part c'est vrai moi
j'ai peur
on va regarder ce que vous faites
vous pouvez m'appeler Manolo j'aime
mieux je préfère donc c'est plus
pratique pour moi
je me retourne plus volontiers quand
j'entends Manolo Castries
il est interdit de circuler dans l'arène
pendant la corrida sauf si vous y êtes
invité ou si vous êtes de la famille du
Taureau
les grandes feuilles les petites
feuilles
du papier de brouillon du papier Canson
et même oui des post-it
mon petit père le 21e siècle sera ou ne
sera pas
dans ma tête
sa meilleure corrida les deux oreilles
la queue et une palette de boîte de thon
à mes dernières corrida c'est pas moi
qui ai fait la bête
un tireur d'élite un vrai pro
et toi ça va t-il le boulot
j'imagine avec tous ces cons qui arrête
pas de pêcher
a
vraiment
[Applaudissements]
qu'est-ce que c'est gros
alors la semaine dernière je crois que
monsieur krivin a adoré mon spectacle
absolument mais venez un petit peu avec
la famille
alors la semaine dernière on a eu
[Musique]
je vais la regarder c'est vrai ça fait
dû être facile tous les jours pour vous
quand vous étiez petit non elle va
comment votre mère elle va bien
partir du moment où elle nourrit trois
fois par jour et qu'on la sort il y a
pas de raison que ça se passe mal
sereine
merci
à peu près le même travail qu'auro sauf
que lui change bon pendant une heure de
combien de 80 mais vous vous en mettez
un costume
je prends mon temps mais à la fin c'est
nickel ah non il y a rien de travers le
pied nickel faut venir voir viens voir
un petit peu bonhomme
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
après juste après en hommage à votre un
hommage à votre père on va baisser la
lumière s'il vous plaît je vous fais à
l'interview casse-couille
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors je pose la question à tout le
monde je vais poser un activine tout à
l'heure vous allez me dire ce que vous
feriez si vous étiez si j'étais
président de
public vous feriez quoi première mesure
je mettrai Coluche Premier ministre très
bien
c'est une bonne idée
[Musique]
il y a quoi
plusieurs choses
alors par exemple je ferai le retour des
pin's parlant d'accord
j'interdirai le prépayant dans les
bibliothèques dans les bibliothèques
de la République
pour tout le monde mais tout nu bien sûr
j'avais prévenu c'est l'interview
casse-couille
attention alors là c'est le grand moment
c'est le climax de cette émission donc à
l'honneur du Festival de Cannes
évidemment nous avons choisi ma femme et
moi des titres de chansons dans
lesquelles il y a des noms de stars et
le blind test s'appelle d'ailleurs star
en chanson oh je dis attention
donc des noms de stars dans le titre
vous allez me dire le nom de la star et
le nom de la chanteuse ou du chanteur
attention Didier
c'est des génies ces mecs
je sais pas si tu veux mais
le bébé le juge de tous qui est là me
dit que c'est que c'est sereine Prévost
le nom de l'actrice Brigitte Bardot
bravo
ça fait deux points pour Olivier un
point pour sereine Prévost problème là
je sais pas il y a un truc tu as pas eu
les filles
j'ai pas payé ma cotisation je crois
mais attendez après il y a le super
banco où tout le monde remet son titre
Olivier chanson numéro 4
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
de cinéma et là effectivement c'est
Vanessa Paradis évidemment noces
blanches bon on continue chanson numéro
c'est bien c'est bien ça fait donc un
point pour Jennifer
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ah oui
je sais ce que c'est non je sais pas
bonjour
[Musique]
vous êtes une star pendant trois
secondes
attention maintenant c'est très très
[Musique]
le titre de la chanson alors
bravo Christine on applaudit
Catherine qui a gagné alors
Olivier a gagné
trois points Olivier est-ce que vous
acceptez de remettre votre titanjeux
pour le super banco Olivier et bien non
et voilà
super banco c'est
ultra dur Didier
je ne sais pas je sais moi
je vous le dis je le sais ça vous étonne
peut-être vous avez pas l'air con là
oui mais qui chante non sa mère pas loin
vous avez pas trouvé personne non on a
déjà mis un truc de lui je vous donne un
indice on a mis une chanson de lui qui
s'appelait je te hais sur le thème de ti
amo
Umberto Tozzi
française de Tiamo sur le thème de je te
hais il a écrit banana split oh là là il
est belge
en plastique
c'est comme tu veux les deux d'accord
bravo
voilà c'était tout le monde en parle
dans Taxi 2 et dans simoncelle sauvetage
explosif sorti le 17 mai Arthur
jusqu'au 17 juin à Mogador Gilbert
Collard Peut-On rire de tout chez Fabre
Jennifer
pourvu que tu m'aimes chez Grasset
sereine Prévost au splendide tous les
soirs à 22h
Mathilde Seigner un ami qui nous veut du
bien de Dominique molle avec Cergy Lopez
le 16 août
caviolivier tous les soirs sur Comédie
la grosse émission et sur Europe 2 qui a
tué Pamela
[Musique]
abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce bleu